foreign
you better prepared on that angle but um
any help would be appreciated I
understand maybe it would help
I can ask when we do these sort of
I mean there's going to be some there's
going to be some areas particularly I
would imagine on the viability of
affordable housing sessions where there
are quite a lot of documents
referred to just by the nature of it and
the number of submissions that have been
provided in appendices Etc
uh but I can ask everybody before each
particular session just to
make it clear what are the main
documents that will be referred to that
is of if that is that is of help yeah
that would be helpful thank you for
example when we do the ecology session
in a short while if uh
it's called work etc but other people
can just sort of refer to the documents
that go into this referring to before to
give you a little chance to to find
those and locate those and get them up
on your screen I appreciate I've got the
benefit of my little screen to big
screens here yeah it's uh I'm I'm lucky
but here's what I'm doing in Bristol but
uh the uh yeah it kind of more difficult
if you're on a uh a laptop or even
mobile phones as I know some people are
on occasionally inquirers and hearing so
if everyone can bows in mind please I
think that's probably a reasonable
request and uh we can provide details of
the purchasing provide details of the
main documents
okay
uh so Mr Dickman so you we had obviously
the drainage and flooding session was
yesterday
uh what was it you wanted to I I don't
some links back to what we're saying
earlier about timetable Etc I really
don't want to get into the habits of
backtracking going back to things these
are sort of something sort of
exceptional that you want to let me know
and it can be brief and it's absolutely
brief uh you're just an expression
yesterday about uh what was known about
the 73 storm just very quickly let you
know that it happened on the night
between the 20s and the 21st of
September 1973. it was over a period of
12 hours and 172 millimeters of water
um fell there's one death uh 23 people
rescued and walls were broken at uh
quicks
sorry Quicks which is uh Wesley uh quick
Spark
right okay
okay thank you is that referred to in
any of your
evidence that presume not by the way
you're bringing to my attention this
morning but is that to refer to in any
of your no we're happy to send that out
that was purely from an article at the
time right okay okay
I don't just sort of encourage sort of
further sort of any sort of risk
evidence being provided at this at this
point but I I know what you're saying
that is
helpful uh
Mr Williams from the appellant's point
of view
if you sort of if there's anything I did
there she wanted to come back to perhaps
that could be incorporated into Mr
uh balls evidence at a later stage
get into a discussion of it now because
we'll be going against what I really
wanted which was to move on with some
sort of pace so well the difficulty with
that of course though is that this is a
Mr Travis I appreciate that and the
inquiry was scheduled to deal with the
third party concerns first and then for
Mr Travis to answer
any questions that third parties had
which he did as it happens one of the
questions raised was the 1973 floods and
Mr Travis confirmed that he was well
aware of them and they were well
documented so on this occasion I don't
think it's a matter that will lead to
any any further difficulty but just to
put down a marker it is difficult if
poets continue to be raised after the
appendant has called its its evidence on
that subject
I appreciate that and I know exactly I I
agree I don't want it you know I don't
want to it's it's it's a formal inquiry
and we need to keep to the program we
can't go back on things uh unfortunately
that's once in this case is the
initiative and that's opportunity if it
was a short short thing but I yeah I
appreciate that Mr Williams Mrs
councilor fans Robin is there anything
you wanted to
say before we move on and I'm pretty
sure that all the evidence on that was
sent in by the Westgate and Garland
Action Group yes I recall detailing up
as well
yeah I recall I recall details have been
sent into so thank you for that
clarification
okay thank you everybody
um
right we can now move back to the
program
um
so we're on item five Midway through
item five
that would be one I just reshuffle a few
things here
um
so yesterday we did the if you like the
habitat regular part of the biodiversity
discussion
now we're looking at the more if you
like sort of site specific
elements and first of all could I just
clarify
who wishes to take part in this
discussion and if I can start with the
appellant please and
Miss Caldwell obviously you want to
participate in this yes Victor
okay anybody else from
Mr Williams I take it you'll be wanting
to contribute where necessary I'll stay
involved awareness I think probably Mr
ball
um will be potentially participating as
well in terms of any discussions that
took place
um as part of the application
okay thank you and Mr Livingstone your
contribution might be helpful I
appreciate that what the council's
position is that there isn't it isn't
objecting on on this issue but uh your
participation would be helpful to I
imagine uh where necessary
yes sir I'll be contributing uh on this
on this issue thank you
okay and turning to the rule six-party
Mr Dickman uh are you or anybody
expecting to contribute to the
discussion
most certainly sir I will be asking a
number of questions and I suspect uh
there may be other people involved that
will wish to
okay who would who might they be
um I see Sarah Bells has raised the hand
and I I would imagine that Sarah would
want to
um but she has raised a hand so perhaps
we'd like to tell you yourself
hi so yes I'm just here um I'm listening
in I'm arrested
Action Group
um it's just questions really that I may
have and if they're not covered by other
people that then I may have some
questions to ask okay okay thank you and
any other interested parties
oops
okay we've got to cancel the parents
I'm assuming you're just saying that you
want to take notes which I can take as
yes please yeah and also Mrs Brown
where are you uh I've seen your hand up
so I think I'm Mark and yes please I'd
like to take part as well thank you okay
okay thank you everybody as this is a
round table discussion it's a slightly
different format to the description that
we had or the session we had on drainage
and
um flooding in the this is rather like a
discussion that everybody's attending a
planning a hearing in the past where I
will lead and ask questions or ask for
contributions from parties or people's
comments so if anybody has questions if
you could ask the questions through me
please uh and I want it to be obviously
a well-mounted discussion which I'm sure
it I'm sure it will be and if we could
avoid the repetition of each other's
points and if we can keep to the agenda
items please and that would be that
would be helpful thank you
um
going back to council francis's point to
the very particular documents that uh
would be particularly helpful for
parties to be aware of or have have open
uh yes uh as identified in the agenda
um I will be referencing the breeding
bird survey report which is CD 8.03
the bar now technical note which is CD
8.06
and the relevant updated es documents
um which is chapter seven on ecology and
that's CD 8.01
um
in other matters I will also be
discussing the biodiversity Net game
report that we produced which forms
appendix 3 of Chris Ball's proof
and CD 9.01 which is the statement of
Common Ground between the appellants and
TDC
I should say that
um chapter seven of the environmental
statement includes appendix 7.5 which is
the bat survey report
yes thank you for clarifying that
okay
thank you
okay just briefly through the agenda
first of all I just want to pick on pick
up on relevant policy requirements
because it's always useful to remind
myself of what those are uh and then I
will ask uh it's called well you just to
go through because obviously there's
been quite a bit of information
submitted post the council's
determination of the appeal so I'd like
you just to sort of go through what that
is and a brief sort of summary of the
results of that or the sort of
conclusions of that that is okay so
everyone can be can be clear
um and then I will ask for comments some
of my questions myself on if you like
the conclusions of your yourself on
those on those matters and then we can
sort of if we can keep that into two
categories first of all upon breeding
birds and then upon bats please so we
can sort of split the two the two up
seems to make sense to me
um
and then another officers want to
include in that any consideration of
mitigation matters because I know
there's been several points raised in
representations from the rule six and
interested parties in that regard
and item e I've got effects of nitrogen
deposition upon charcoal Farm res
roadside nature reserve and that's what
clarification on this because I think
in the uh in your environmental
statement there there is an effect upon
that and uh I want to sort of clarify
what that is how it has been mitigated
and what the residual effects of that is
I know that's not actually mentioned in
your proof but it's just going back to
what I read previously in the
environmental statement and then at the
end briefly uh if just provide people's
conclusions against the relevant policy
requirements and I've got any other
relevant matters as well and one of my
things was to raise the uh
net biodiversity gain as well which I
think you've already picked up on yeah
so that is that's helpful thank you okay
so the first part the relevant policy
considerations I think the sort of a the
main policy development plan policy
anyway is policy SP
30 and would anybody like just to give a
brief sort of obviously I sort of read
this but just so everybody is sort of
aware just a brief summary of this I
mean I don't know I don't mind who does
this Mr Livingstone you're there if you
want to do it oh Mr but I really don't
don't mind uh I I I don't mind giving a
giving a brief summary of this um so the
the policy itself is is effectively the
biodiversity policy that's in the local
plan which requires that development
proposals will make positive
contribution to the conservation
enhancement and management of
biodiversity and uh geodiversity assets
um resulting in a net gain for
biodiversity and that's through a number
of measures which are identified in the
policy which includes restoration
enhancement of existing habitats
um where appropriate uh the creation of
new wildlife habitats creation of
linkages between sites to create
um you know local and Regional
ecological networks as well as
protecting soils um skating against the
loss of Farmland bird habitats
um and it also goes on to talk about
um basically assessing the presence of
assets on sites and protected species
um and then talks about uh some of the
issues that we we sort of discussed
yesterday in part about
um the sort of special protection area
making sure that functioning link land
is assessed within submissions
um and you know when that's the case an
assessment will be required
um and then just to give you the last
sentence so that everyone's aware it
states the planning permission will not
be granted for development if it results
in significant harm to biodiversity and
geodiversity assets which cannot be
adequately mitigated or as a last resort
compensated for to the satisfactory uh
satisfaction of the appropriate
Authority
okay
thank you and just
on the
net biodiversity game which I think you
mentioned that there's not actually a
there's a requirement of climate four is
the enhancement of certificate features
of nature conservation
value oh actually net gain is at the top
isn't it it's at the top okay
yeah I see
okay thank you
any comments on that from
the appellant is called well are you
happy with that summary I just want to
sort of say it's clear in everyone's
mind what the actual because sometimes
we sort of go straight into issues about
firstly looking at what the what the
policy requirements are so I thought it
was helpful in this regard anything you
wanted to add
I think that provides a good summary
thank you and is everyone happy that
it's consistent with the uh framework
thank you
I've seen nuts
as in the mpps yeah sorry yes yes
um yes the wording particularly in
regards to mitigation and or
compensation reflection ppf okay
thank you
okay and obviously we compare the policy
requirements in mind as we go through
the discussion okay moving on to
Item B and this is a consideration of
the further information provided by the
appellant as I said Miss Conway you
could you know for the benefit of
everybody here some people might have
read the the further information others
might not not have if you can just do a
sort of a brief sort of summary of the
further information and the sort of key
findings from the appellants position
that you have found please
yes sir so uh the breeding bird survey
report which is CD
8.03 uh details the results of breeding
bird surveys undertaken between April
and June 2020
um methods are provided in uh paragraph
3.3 to 3.9
in terms of the results uh we confirmed
that 26 species were considered to be
breeding on site that includes potential
possible and probable breeders and the
definition of which is included in the
methodology
um which were considered to be holding
one or more breeding territories within
the application sites with a total of 40
species recorded So some species which
were not considered to be breeders and
may just be passing over
um
this was considered to be a relatively
low diversity for the size of the site
and in accordance with the assessment
methodology identified by Fuller which
is an industry standard and we concluded
the site was of local importance for
breeding birds
it's notable that
um we recorded nine red listed breeding
species
um 11 red list in total recorded on the
site and this included grape Partridge
corn Bunting and Skylark which are all
declining farmer Birds species
however these are all recorded in
relatively low numbers with three
territories of for Skylark identified
two breeding territories for Ray
Partridge and one breeding territory for
corn bunting being identified
as set out within the breeding bird
survey report we have Quantified the
level of significance of these breeding
territories set against the
um County population records for these
species
indicating that the number of breeding
territories on site is a very low
percentage in terms of County
county numbers and therefore we we
concluded that the site was of local
importance for gray Partridge and call
Bunting and of site level importance for
Skylark which are more widespread and
abundant
in terms of other breeding birth species
um uh most of these were sort of
widespread and
a fairly common species mostly
associated with boundary habitats trees
hedgerows Etc whereas grape artridge
corn bouncing and Skylark uh are birds
of open Farmland nesting on open ground
[Music]
in line with um chapter seven of the
environmental statement
um this was produced prior to the
reading books so the information being
available we also concluded that the
site was likely to be of local
importance for breeding bird species
based on the habitat types present and
the records that we had received from
chem biological record Center
um so although we had identified these
three rarest species on site in very low
numbers the overall conclusions of the
es did not materially change
I should mention that
um swra undertook their own Wildlife
survey of the site
um I have raised
various points about the methods and
conclusions that they have made a part
of that survey which I do not consider
to be robust however they did record a
similar number of species 40 species on
site
and only three Riddler species all of
which were also recorded by CSA so the
information that's provided within that
additional Wildlife survey report I do
not consider materially changes my
assessment
okay
would you like me to talk about bar now
now and then my mitigation sir or would
you like me to continue to focus on the
final bird species
well I think you're on mute sorry for
sorry I didn't quite well on that
yesterday but not so far today
um so
yeah just a question for me could you
just explain because you said that for
the
um
gray Partridge and corn bunting this
local impact and for the sky Lark site
of site so low so I have local importers
in fact local importers Skylark site
level importance what is explain the
meanings of those those terms because
you mentioned also sort of counter-level
importance local important site level
importance can you explain a bit more on
the meaning of those terms yes sir so in
line with the same guidelines for
environmental impact assessment which is
what all professional ecologists work to
um that's our Institute standard
um
we determine significance
um of populations and significance of
effects in terms of a geographical
context
so
um for example
um European designated sites we were
talking about yesterday
um are considered to be of international
importance
and it sequentially goes down through
international national County local and
Below local I.E site level important and
the level of importance assigned
um is based on relative population
numbers or individual species or in the
case of breeding birds the diversity of
the assemblage of breeding birds and
Fuller has produced a methodology for
assigning those Geographic contexts of
importance and
26 species breeding species confirmed on
a site would be akin to what he
identifies as local level importance and
we would agree with that as well
okay thank you any comments from anybody
on what's being said
so far
Mr Dickman yes thank you sir um
I I do have problems understanding the
Red List notion
uh presumably they're birds in Decline
which would indicate that they will be
in small numbers
in any case
what I can't quite understand is the
notion of doing this geographically
surely if a bird is endangered and on
the Red List it's important that they're
protected now given that
um if a number of authorities within the
county took the stance when it's local
so therefore
and it's not of that significance and
that happened nationally then we would
run the risk of actually losing
endangered species so I can't quite
understand
how you put a bird on a red list because
it's in Decline and there are a few of
them then you say well there aren't very
many therefore it's okay in this case
um so I
maybe maybe a little bit more
clarification on that so I just really
want to make the point that I can't
quite understand that whole notion why
they are on the red list if indeed
you're not going to protect them
okay it's called we would like to
respond to that please
yes certainly so in terms of the local
level importance with your type aside
that is in relation to the bird
assemblage so that looks at diversity of
the assemblage so we're trying to
identify which are the richest sites for
bird interest versus those sites that
are not as Rich alongside that we look
at the conservation importance of the
individual species identified and that's
why we specifically picked out green
Partridge cornbreaking and Skylark
because they are endless species and
therefore we want to acknowledge that
although they are in loan numbers
that's really important having said that
um
the number of territories that we've
identified for those individual species
is very low in the context of their
distribution within the county
so I'm not trying to downplay the
importance of the conservation
importance of those species in terms of
their own listing but we are looking at
the
impact specifically on the number of
territories that will be lost by this
proposed development and that's where
our level of geographical impact comes
from
does that help to answer your question
I'm not being abusive and I can't
understand the notion that you have
registered birds in Decline so therefore
they will be low in numbers the notion
that they they are alone that so
therefore
um there's not a large impact I I can't
quite understand because if you take
that stance uh on many occasions then
you lose those numbers shortly the vague
notion that they're on a red list and
that they're in Decline means that every
uh every bird every breeding pair need
to be nurtured need to be looked after
otherwise we lose them and I still can't
understand this notion that okay well
there's only a few here well there will
only be a few because they're in Decline
so therefore it's okay to just ignore
them
so we haven't downplayed the importance
of those species being present on site
we have acknowledged that the presence
even in low number of those species is
of local importance
um what we're looking at in our impact
assessment is what would be the effect
what would be the level of effect
of the loss or displacement of those
species those territories so we've
looked at this in a geographical context
which is what we're guided to do by
saying impact assessment guidelines you
know for example gray partridge
we've looked at the loss or displacement
of two territories in the context of the
population numbers published for the
county for Kent and that equates to 0.33
so a very low percentage so when we
think about what the level of that
impact might be if we were losing
um
50 of uh those territories identified
within the county then of course the
level of effect would be much greater
but it's not in this case so I do take
your point that every territory is
important but how important and that's
what we've addressed within our
environmental statement
thank you I mean in terms of the effects
on those breeding birds and putting
aside mitigation I like kind of
mitigation in the moment in terms of
again going back to the policy
without your writing saying that in
terms of the effects of The Proposal on
those breeding birds you expect what you
said about the
local importers and site level importers
that effect would still be significant
in terms of the obviously there's
different variations and levels of
significance but the effect there would
be a significant adverse effect on those
breeding birds in the context of the the
policy putting aside mitigation
yes that is what we have concluded that
there would be a significant effect
because
those territories will be displaced from
the site
um you know with the breeding species
that will use hedgerows trees
Etc then the effect is less because
those resources will be maintained on
site and will come on to mitigation and
enhancement but in terms of the Farmland
bird species of course by virtue of the
land take
we can't maintain those territories on
site they will be displaced and
therefore there is an effect
okay thank you and in terms and in terms
of the level of significance what would
that
what would that be using using sort of
an appropriate sort of scales obviously
significant it could be you know it
could be moderately significant it could
be you know uh
different magnitude Etc where would you
place it in terms of the levels
yeah we're guided to use this
Geographic biodiversity rather than the
major minor uh level effects that you
might see in some other ES
disciplines
um
because we have valued the populations
of great Partridge at the local level
and we have said we will be displacing
all of the country is identified we have
identified that as a local level impact
in the absence of mitigation
similarly for Skylark site level
okay thank you is it worth now not
exactly keeping to my agenda but moving
on to mitigation for breeding birds as
we're talking about breeding birds then
we can move on to the other
um bats Etc uh do you want to just
outline the there's a hand got it from
Miss Powers do you have anything to say
at this point
oh yeah I do have something to say about
breeding birds if you're moving if
you're thinking
um we the residents did have a survey
done right at the end of the breeding
bird season season and the ecologist
hasn't referred to that a number of
times in her as she was speaking I know
she doesn't think it's a very good
survey I just wanted to um to make it
clear why that survey was done in the
first place so I am the resident that
requested the breeding bird survey on
multiple occasions starting the middle
of last year because I knew it should be
done well I felt that it should be done
because we knew that breeding birds were
there the Brewing bird survey was not
evident in the submission at all and we
asked for it multiple occasions
um and we tried to have this discussion
that we're having now at the planned
committee meetings on three occasions
breeding birdie survey was not
forthcoming so the first time we've seen
it was when it was written uh in
November I think and sent to us in
December so I just wanted to well I
guess two things come from that really
this was the reason we tried to do our
own survey which we completely concur is
not a full breeding birth survey we're
totally agree with that but my question
really is why did we never have the
breeding birth survey that was actually
performed in 2020 are not written up
until November 2021 despite us
requesting it on several occasions
because all of this discussion could
have happened before
okay thank you and I understand because
that's been already said in writing and
I think that's been responded to but
miss Caldwell could you just briefly
respond to that that question please of
the timing please
that's correct the breeding bird survey
was done in 2020 as we've reported
um
that was not provided it's my
understanding because it was never
requested by the council or KCC
um by the time that they need to have
been written up then KCC had provided a
written consultation response which did
not raise any
issues regarding the bird survey data or
requesting the bird survey data and that
is my understanding that
um when it was requested by pins as part
of this appeal that is the first time
that that date is been asked for
okay thank you and it's this question is
for these flowers do you agree with the
like we're Stanley what's been said
about the timing I don't want to go over
lots of detail on that because I'm not
sure it's going to really be at the end
of the day overly helpful to me in terms
of coming to my decision and
deliberation on these matters but but I
do appreciate what you've what you've
said and what's being said on this but
do you agree with the findings of
repellents reading birth survey in terms
of the without mitigation in terms of
the the impacts
that have been outlined I'm I'm not a
trained colleges so I don't understand
the levels of impact all I know is that
as a resident who lives next to those
fields I know there are we hear skylarks
all the time and every day and they will
be gone because their habitat will be
gone obviously
um so from a resident I suppose a site
level perspective because that's where
we live it will have a huge impact
um but I guess in ecology speak that is
a site-level impact
returning to the breeding bird survey
um I don't know whether perhaps Mr
Livingston might like to comment on why
the request for the breeding survey
weren't passed on to uh the appellant
perhaps
okay
where's this briefly I don't want to get
into detail on this I'm not sure it's
going to be overly helpful in terms of
I've got to go on the information that's
before we get the present the present
time I don't want to stop talking about
what might have happened in the past I
appreciate their concerns about that
just briefly in that regard Mr
Livingston and you want to make a
comment
thank you yeah the environmental
statement of this section seven was was
he looked at by KCC as the councils who
appointed ecologists who looked at the
work that had been submitted and also
looked obviously the habitat that was
present on the site to assess whether or
not obviously that the potential for uh
you know nesting Birds farmer Birds Etc
and then considered there obviously the
the significance in terms of the impact
at the local level agreed with that
assessment and then uh considered the
mitigation that was then put forward in
the in the section which obviously then
we took on board as the advice present
now obviously we'll come on to the
mitigation that's that's now being
proposed in the next topic because I
think obviously that's the most relevant
to you sir in terms of the determination
at this point in time
thank you
okay excuse me a second
um
sorry Mr Williams
thank you so just listening to the
debate before we move on to mitigation I
thought it might be helpful just to
follow up Mr Dickman's point if Mrs
Caldwell could explain why when you're
considering the geographical approach to
cite importance
why do you assess against
county level population levels of that
species and how does that then feed into
the impact
assessment because Mr Dickman's concern
was that where you're dealing with
um regular species they might be in
general population terms in quite low
numbers and I just wanted you to explain
if you could the role of assessing it
against County levels
okay
thank you
um so in terms of um impact assessment
um and indeed valuation we
would look at
what does our site constitute in terms
of a breeding bird resource in terms of
those Geographic levels
starting from the bottom is it important
at the site level well yes we've got
regular species on our side so the site
is important the site the application
site is important at that level for
those for those species the next level
up we look at local or County how does
our the numbers of breeding birds on our
site
um look against the
um
county level population well as I've
already said
um the very low number of territories uh
two territories for great Partridge or a
very low percentage 0.33
of the county level population
if you scaled that up and looked at the
national territory numbers great
Partridge 37
000 territories are two territories that
were impacting would be a very low
percentage of that so either two
territories significant at the national
level I would very much argue that
they're not now that's not to say that
we don't have to impact at the site that
mitigate at the site level
but our level of impact is certainly not
significant at the national level even
though the red listing of species
clearly
um is to do with national population
Trends
um not just numbers but Trends in terms
of declines or breeding success
does that help to answer that point
um I would have to say not I'm afraid I
I still can't understand the notion of
having a red list for a species in
Decline and then
quite frequently saying well we will
lose some but it doesn't really matter
it'll be a small number in the general
scheme of things these birds are
endangered and everyone matters
um and I I guess that's where we will uh
uh not agree on that
okay thank you in that regard I think
I've got the information before me that
I need to come to you know conclusions
that which of course is my my job in all
this so I'm I'm aware of sort of what
your views on that files have to go away
and consider those
um
is there anything further you wanted to
add before we move on to mitigation
thank you just very briefly I I have to
say I I I'm struggling like Mr Dickman
is to um understand this because I would
have thought if it's if they are only
important at site level that makes them
very important if they're an endangered
species
um I am struggling with that but I also
do want to mention on behalf of my
residents
um that people do talk about the
skylarks a lot of people who live along
shot and down Road
um have talked a lot about the skylarks
um and the wildlife that is there so um
local knowledge again
um maybe could be considered thank you
okay thank you and this uh Mrs Brown
thank you sir
I just wanted to mention that this is
this is going to have a cumulative
effect across than it because there's
lots of Farmland across than it which is
is being looked at is being developed so
we lose this site and then we'll lose
another site and then before we know it
all these endangered birds have lost
their habitat
okay
thank you
um
it's called if that's come back to those
two on those two points please
yes sir um on Mrs farren's point about
Skylark
um one thing I would just like to make
you aware of in terms of Skylark is
in terms of their ecology they are a
very visible species they have this
display flight where they go up very
high in the sky and they're very vocal
and they can call for a long period of
time and they are very visible in
contrast to some more cryptic species
now this Behavior does not necessarily
relate to the number of breeding
territories that we have identified on
our side so I'm not trying to get away
from the fact that we do have breeding
Skylark on our side and that is
important but in terms of sort of local
perception
are a very visible species
um that are easy to notice
um so that's my point on that
and the second point on cumulative level
impacts that was assessed within our es
chapter
and of course we must bear in mind that
sp30 does have a specific requirement
for
um farm and bird mitigation
and therefore any scheme coming forward
must have due regard to Farmland birds
and provide adequate mitigation and or
compensation
as appropriate
in addition there was some detailed
survey work in relation to wintering
birds and other breeding bird species
um in production of the local plan to
look at the sites
um that would be least impacted by
development in that regard
so in terms of cumulative impacts
yes in the absence of assessment and or
mitigation as required there could be a
cumulative impact but
um we must assume that all Development
coming forward is bound by the same
policy that we are and therefore
um a cumulative effect cannot occur
thank you
foreign
is that a hand from previously or is
there something no I I just wanted to
say I'm I know you probably want to stop
this discussion sir I apologize but but
if each site that comes forward assesses
these birds as only being important at
the site level and it doesn't matter
then you know gradually they are going
to disappear if each site concludes the
same as the ecologists here have
concluded then every Skylark will not
matter and every site will go and there
will be no skylarks going forward
okay thank you and sir Roger did you
want to add anything at this point very
briefly sir I've listened to this with
great interest so I understand it's
Caldwell's um expertise
but I think the point that's been made
by Sarah Bowers is absolutely valid
we have already lost for example the red
build chuff
from Kent the the bird is effectively
apart from in captivity extinct
um there are others that will follow and
it simply cannot be right to say that
um we can look at the bigger picture and
therefore in terms of site specificity
not bother
um because if we allow that domino
effect to take place then as I've
indicated in all the in other comments
with the relation to the loss of
agricultural land
pretty soon we're going to have no
habitat left at all and that would be an
absolute ecological disaster so I'm
afraid I cannot accept my score well to
arguments thank you
thank you and
Miss Caldwell
I'll give you as the account the final
opportunities to comment before we move
on to mitigation
please thank you sir
I would just like to clarify that
although we have identified the level of
impact in relation to farming bird
species
um we have identified a significant
impact at the local level so I reject
the comments that say
um we have said that there is no effect
and that it doesn't matter that's that's
not the case we have rationalized what
level of effect we think there will be
and we have proposed mitigation and
compensation accordingly
thank you
okay thank you can we now move on to
mitigation this is litigation just for
in terms of what we've been talking
about for the breeding birth can you
just summarize the mitigation that has
been proposed
yes sir so as set out with you within
original es chapter submitted with the
application
we set out
um the level of New Habitat creation and
enhancement that we could be delivered
um in line with the proposed landscape
strategy
um and the amount of open space
um proposed within the dfp
development framework plan that is
um and for the majority of species
um that will result in a positive effect
um
the availability of hedgerows Thicket
planting Wildflower grassland planting
um it's gas in this area which is
dominated by arable farmland and
therefore this will these will be new
and enhanced resources for the majority
of breeding birds species
subsequent to the detail received on the
breeding bird survey report and the
identification of these Farm Number
species we have also specified a
specific bird mitigation area within the
south eastern part of the site which
totals 0.08 hectares
which will be uh
fenced off
um and specifically provided and managed
for wildlife and bird mitigation in
particular
um the fencing office to reduce
disturbance from
um new residents
and the planting proposed within that
area will comprise
um a suitable uh native wildflower
grassland mix a tusky mix that will
produce lots of seed and invertebrate
resource for a range of breeding bird
species but specifically to boost the
potential breeding success of the farm
number species
um we've identified would be impacted
now I think there's been a slight
misinterpretation about the purpose of
that breeding about bird mitigation area
in that
um it may provide some nesting habitat
for some species
um such as gray Partridge which will
nest in Headroom bases adjacent to open
areas but its primary reason is to boost
resources available for
um from the birds breaches which we
accept may be displaced to adjacent
Farmland so the location of the bird
mitigation area is on the southern edge
of the site which borders
um
remaining open Farm into the South
um and it's been shown that an increase
in availability of seed resource all
year round and particularly insects grub
SARS reports and during the breeding
season to feed chicks boost breeding
success
um so this is not strictly a mitigation
but a compensation measure because by
nature of the development
um we will lose territories on site
through land take
um I think that's the basic outline
in terms of the thank you in terms of
the bird mitigation area
you'll have probably read concerns that
have been raid by raised by the local
residents about its
location in terms of proximity to uh
houses in terms of I think proximity to
erode and things like implicate
implications for pets and and can you
provide a but there's obviously the
opportunity to come back on
on those comments that have been
provided by residents which sort of seem
to sort of undermine the value of that
what has been proposed in terms of that
open space proposal and what its actual
contribution would be mitigating the
significant effect
yes sir so in terms of disturbance and
it has been raised about monster Road uh
to the East and the recycling facility
um Etc obviously they're features that
are already present and we're already
we're recording these regular species in
the part of the site that we're
proposing the bird mitigation area so
there is a certain degree of uh
habituation
um to those potential disturbing factors
with regards to pets
obviously that on the site is already
surrounded by some residential
development and uh to a certain degree
that effect may already occur
um we have acknowledged within our um
chapter seven of the US that it could be
an adverse effect
um from increased predation so that's
been built into our assessments
um already
um but despite that
um these habitats will provide more
cover than is currently available
um for these breeding species which
should help to eliminate some of the
facts effects of predation
and the new prey availability for
breeding birds uh you know should help
to boost their breathing success so
um I am not trying to get away from the
fact there may be an effect from from
predation from pets Etc but on balance
we feel that this would still be an
adequate compensation
thank you and just in terms of one of
the things you said that you said the
habitat will provide more cover than
previously available do you mean sort of
it'll provide more cover for breeding
birds than what was previously available
in terms of the the open Farmland is
that what yeah so the landscape
proposals apart from the specific bird
mitigation area includes uh you know
lots of Hedgerow planting I think we've
got over a kilometer of Hedgerow
planting and we've got significant new
mixed scrub provision
um just Joy of half a hectare a scrub
provision and
over two hectares of uh Wildflower
grassland planting which will be
Tuskegee in nature so these habitats
don't currently exist on this site it's
quite a quite a Barren landscape
um really where an arable landscape so
these features will provide more cover
for the majority of breeding birth
species that we're recording on the site
okay just for my own clarification and
in terms of the obviously I think you've
touched those but in terms of
significant effect on
great Parts Etc Skylark and core bunting
that's been identified you're not saying
that this mitigation would actually mean
that you'd get if you like replacement
breeding territories as I understand it
you're saying that it'll be
breeding territories for other birds but
not necessarily the ones that would be
significantly affected is that right or
have I got that slightly wrong
there will certainly be lots more
breeding opportunity for other bird
species in relation to these three
Farmland bird species
um the primary purpose of the bird
mitigation area is to boost
um prey and forage availability it
reproduce some opportunities for nesting
but we accept that more likely
territories will be displaced to
adjacent farmland
okay
and
go back to policy SB 30 part 6 says
mitigating one of the
measures it it it it it sees compliance
with is mitigating against the loss of
Farmland bird habitats
perhaps Mr Livingstone if you could
a question for you perhaps in terms of
the sort of the council's interpretation
of that policy does that mean mitigating
against the loss of Farmland bird
habitats what is that sort of what's the
expectation of the council in that
respect obviously the council is not
subjecting on on this matter but does
that mean that mitigating as a loss of
Farmland bird habitats means that
mitigation could actually be to
encourage other birds but not
necessarily Farmland bird habitats which
it seems would be lost in terms of these
two two sides I appreciate the point it
was called or that they might go on to
adjacent sites Etc but what's the
intention of that place of the policy in
that regard
um I think obviously inherently within
strategic allocations on
um on Farmland sites there's there's the
potential for impact on existing
habitats uh and obviously this policy is
taken in the round of the local plan and
all the other allocations I think in
terms of the specifics of this policy in
terms of mitigating against the the loss
of farm and bird habitats obvious see
what we looked at
within the consideration the application
is is what measures have been put in
place within the landscaping that's
provided within the scheme to ensure
that you're basically trying to ensure
that as much
um as many habitats as possible are
either created a new in in the locations
to which they are so which could as you
say so it actually introduced you know
different bird species there or or
potentially improve actually the
ecological value of certain parts of the
site
um but I think there's there's you know
there is an element here which is that
sites like this can result in uh
certainly displacement of of Farmland
bird habitats by their very nature of
being allocated and being changed I
think uh you know the intention is is to
try and ensure that as much as can be
done within the round
um that those impacts are are mitigated
to a degree
um obviously you know preservation in
situ is is is more tricky with certain
sides
um
I think if I if I may I did want to come
on to a couple of the points that come
up about this particular bit of
mitigation is it is it an appropriate
time to come in now sorry I appreciate
Mr Dickman's got his hand up should
ultimately be first uh as you're as
you're as you're you're on is that all
right sorry
um I just wonder if it's possible to
just get some idea of
um
the the two points obviously from from
the council side of things obviously
um is this mitigation area is is sort of
a new element of mitigation that's come
out of of the additional information
that's been been published I think uh
obviously we were satisfied with the
information upon submission of the
application and and indeed the uh what
Miss cordless talked about is is not I
mean it's not fundamentally opposed to
the assessment of impacts that have
occurred within the determination
application but in terms of the
mitigation I just wonder if it's
possible to find out a bit more about
the dissemination that's the size of
this area because obviously the
ramifications of it which admittedly
will probably knock onto our discussion
about conditions
is about the fact that it's proposed to
be fenced off to avoid disturbance of
this area
um and so it's just wondering if it's
possible to find out about the the size
in particular and how that's been
determined
yeah absolutely Miss Caldwell please if
you can respond to that
well
location of the proposed mitigation area
the location has been selected I mean
you have to look at the the scheme
available we have to look where would be
a good location for this bird mitigation
to be provided well it must be provided
adjacent to
um
The Wider landscape and arable resources
available for it to be effective so the
southern southwestern part of the site
lends itself to that
we kind of ignore that we already had a
large area of landscaping proposed there
so that was in the original development
framework plan and the original
landscape strategy so all we've done is
looked at how much of that
um existing landscape area we could
dedicate to bird mitigation to maximize
our mitigation and compensation on site
within the scheme in that part of the
site we have this archeology exclusion
area
which is of a similar size
um so no development or or significant
um Landscaping could be achieved within
that part of the site my archeology and
Heritage colleague has confirmed with
tdc's archeology officer that the type
of landscaping that we're proposing
within the bird mitigation area would
not contrave what's required by the
archeology exclusion area and similarly
my landscape colleagues have confirmed
that provision of the Landscaping
proposed would not impact the landscape
and visual impact assessment that's
already been undertaken and that the
level of accessible immunity space is
still policy compliant and we have
provided a separate POS note on that
point
which was updated recently
um
does that help to answer your question
can I just ask a question a follow-up
question about that in terms of there's
a separate space being provided that as
I understand that this will be public
open space where people will be
encouraged to exercise children play Etc
how can it be guaranteed that
obviously for my thinking these areas
the bird area needs to be as little
disturbance as possible in terms of sort
of opportunities for people to sort of
take their dogs for a little bit of
exercise for children to you know climb
over things and sort of explore and so
there's a taking this kind of proximity
Residential Properties what sort of
Surety can there be that actually this
space will do what it's intended to do
bear in mind you know bearing in mind
human nature people walking dogs Etc
where you've got such proximity to the
actual residential dwellings that are
being proposed
you know in terms of um play provision
um there have been some specific areas
identified on the landscape strategy in
terms of play provision and one of the
main areas for that is along the uh
North where are we north western side of
shot and Dane road so there's a new
linear Park that will be provided as
part of the scheme and the trim trail
that runs through that linear Park so
that will be a focus for that kind of
recreation in addition there's a smaller
pay provision area which is within the
um area of landscaping off manston road
north of
um whether the mitigation area is
proposed but there are more informal
areas of Wildflower planting moon path
Etc provided around that between the
play provision
and the bird mitigation area so there is
a bit of a buff that's still allowed
there and the POS note confirms adequate
provision in fact over provision in
terms of the policy in terms of
accessible Green Space
and what would actually those stop
people going on this the the uh what are
you calling it The Bird
mitigation Zone that's probably not the
term you use but
what actually measures will be proposed
to ensure that's the case in perpetuity
well as we said fencing will be provided
signage and interpretation could be
provided we have identified that a
homeowner information pack would be
provided to new residents which would
give them information about the bird
mitigation area and other biodiversity
mitigation and enhancements on site and
that that would help to at least inform
and guide behaviors of new residents and
a condition has been suggested to secure
that
okay and just one last question for me
before I allow any comments was any
consideration given to the provision of
off-site mitigation in this respect
which might sort of not have the risks
of a of an on-site location
you know off-site provision could be an
option I know that other schemes have
um
looked at doing some
um Farmland Birds
um improvements on adjacent land where
that's under their control and that's
not not the situation that we're in here
and that's not been asked for by TDC and
I'm not aware that GDC have a formal
off-site
um Compensation Program for farming
Birds up and running perhaps the income
I could um
comment on that
um but we do consider that the measures
provide thus far would would be uh
sufficient a sufficient level of
compensation
okay thank you Mr Livingston you want to
briefly sort of come back to that
thank you sir to my knowledge there is
no as as said there is no uh scheme um
specifically for uh compensatory
environments for for Farmland Burns
okay thank you there's a couple of hands
gone up and I think
Mr Dickman you were first I think
thanks sir
um
yes okay
um it is adjacent to Madison Road which
is an extremely busy road at certain
times of the year uh during the summer
months holiday traffic uh making its way
through often gridlocked a lot of cars
goes to the tip and so therefore we feel
that that habitat is unlikely to be
successful certainly when you look at
the red-listed birds uh the great
Partridge won't uh go anywhere near
fenced off area so and certainly the sky
like on the corn bun to rely on Open
Fields that's how they function
um as to any many of the filters they
they rely on the Open Fields to feed and
nest and so we feel that um that really
isn't and indeed the area that it's in
was actually the archaeological area
um which what they
one can only assume that they've picked
that area because they couldn't build on
it in any case but perhaps I've been
disingenuated
um
so we feel that that mitigation isn't
um anywhere near
um
what it should be
I was pleased that you asked the
question about the surrounding area
because
um despite packs going to families it
already happens with local residents
people will walk their dogs over fields
um and well not necessarily stick to the
footpaths and if you look at the um uh
the
statement from gladman's design access
statement plus map it actually States
public right-of-way a network of public
rights away across the surrounding
farmland and provide attractive routes
into Market the main nature of that
means that it's going to direct people
down off the the site and across those
fields
um
of course that also then means that any
chance that those registered Birds had
are likely to be
um
negated because any animals running
across there will chase them off
so we feel that it is inadequate we then
we do acknowledge that they have various
areas of plan to but those fairs are
exploding are within the cartilage and
the site of the um the estate and as you
quite rightly say children will be
playing dogs will be running around and
I suspect the only birds that will
really want to uh find a way in their
their seagulls and the large non-proof
crows that live in and around the
cemetery
okay
thank you if I go to Sir Roger are you
happy to miss gold or just respond if I
get all the interesting party's views in
one go and I can come back to you to
respond sir so so Roger thank you very
much sir I I share the concerns that
you've expressed about this
um first of all in terms of alternative
sites
um of course you could say well there's
the the cemetery and there's the
crematorium land and there's you know a
lot of habit out there yes there is
but those are different species of
miscope notes we are talking about not
only ground nesting Birds
um and Hedgerow nesting Birds but also
mammals small mammals as well
and it is impossible to protect that
habitat if you confine it to a narrow
area particularly if you are also using
that area
as public open space because the two
just can't live side by side you need
the open space for these species to
survive we all know that
and a question please which is my
understanding unless I've misread the
map is that what started as an
of archaeological
protected area
that sort of metamorphosed into doubling
as a habitat protected area so they are
one and the same
well I'm sorry but if the archaeological
protected area is of any value then
people will want to excavate it if
you're going to excavate it you're
immediately going to disturb the habitat
so again those two if I've read this
correctly are not compatible
the mitigation simply will not work in
the way the scoreboard is suggested and
I think you've identified that yourself
sir
okay thank you and
counselor Faraz
please obviously if there's anything you
want to repeat then don't just repeat
what's mean but any new points please
I also have a dislike of repetition
um now it's just a quick question really
um with all this obviously in-depth
discussion about mitigation
um I I'm just hoping that Miss Caldwell
or or whoever uh would represent Garden
developments has discussed all this with
the uh our excellent biodiversity
officer at Planet District Council who
obviously has an in-depth knowledge of
the area
um so I I just wanted to check that
those discussions have taken place thank
you okay thank you and finally Mrs Brown
thank you sir
I just want you to ask why isn't there
compensatory
sorry
why isn't there compensate compensatory
provision for Farmland Birds
see you okay thank you there's several
points there is this call so I think
that's all the hands that I've dealt
with so if you could respond to each
in turn please
thank you sir
um
I'll start with the point on the
archeology exclusion area
yes it's correct that that area largely
measured mirrors the area provided for
bird mitigation
um
some might say that's a effective use of
space given the viability of this site
is is one of the key
points being discussed at this appeal
um but the point about
um people wanting to excavate the
archaeological uh interest there is a
void one really because the strategy
there is to retain in situ and preserve
and that is what has been with agreed
with the archeology officer and the
fencing off of that area surely will
benefit people not accessing that area
for such
reasons or you know resulting in erosion
of soils or anything like that so I
completely reject that point
um
in terms of consultation with TDC
um obviously TDC have consulted their
ecological advisors at KCC and they have
raised no objection and they have
largely agreed with the conclusions that
we made within our environmental
statement
um particularly in regard to
potential conditions that could be used
to secure some of the biodiversity
mitigation and enhancement measures
and therefore we have got confirmation
from TDC that that's adequate
um
with regards to the compensatory
measures
um the bird mitigation and providing on
site is the compensatory measure so I'm
not quite sure what Mrs Brown referred
to there perhaps that was in relation to
off-site measures
um yeah um I didn't um Mr Livingston
said something about not now um
um compensation most of the first file
members
um
so just to clarify my my point was in
response to the the question about
whether or not there was a council
strategy which related to compensatory
environments that were in place already
for Farmland birds as part of maybe a
strategic overview of development
through the local Plan Generation that
that's and through the adoption of that
it wasn't it's not a scheme that is in
existence obviously the policy framework
in its entirety is in place uh to
protecting those measures but there
isn't a scheme appointments that there
isn't a distinct strategy or scheme like
the sounds that we were discussing
yesterday
I understand thank you
thank you for clarifying that
um and I think the last point was Mr
Dickman's point about uh that he doesn't
feel that this is adequate mitigation or
compensation
um my professional judgment is that I
disagree with that and that given the
number of territories that would be
affected by this proposal and the
level of compensation that will be
provided in terms of new habitats and
which should be
breeding success
on adjacent land and I'm talking about
open Farmland in relation to open
Farmland birds not the cemetery in
relation to other breeding birds which
which may use the habitats there and
that we believe that um the level of
compensation proposes is adequate
okay thank you and again this is the
matter I'm gonna have to go away and
consider are there any there's two hands
back up uh stigma is if you briefly you
want to add the if not already
said
Mr Dickman thank you sir um yes um
gratman's also offer Lance the self of
area BS mitigation
um and indeed have noted that this
belongs to third party has that third
party been approached in terms of that
mitigation
it's called intellectual response to
that
we have not proposed we have not
approached
um any third parties uh as as far as I'm
aware in terms of securing off-site
mitigation we haven't actually proposed
any Mitigation Of site my observation is
that although we are providing the bird
mitigation area that some Farmers
species may be displaced to adjacent
Farmland so there's no specific
mitigation action being proposed on
third party land
and finally um
I noticed on the map on your statement
on public rights way which is figure
three gladness design and access
statement plus map that you have
um two zones uh 400 meters Zone and an
800 meters Zone across the Farmland I I
wonder
um is there any calculation as to the
amount of Farmland that would be lost or
affected due to that
do you mean in terms of disturbance from
you
the fact that it is still working
farmland
to my knowledge tm14 is an existing
footpath route public right-of-way that
runs along the sort of boundary of our
site between shutterton road and manston
road
um and that obviously there will be
increased use of that resulting from the
development potentially
um but that we're not suggesting that uh
there'll be any access across open
farmlands it's not part of a public
right-of-way
um
so I'm a little bit confused by your
comment uh and in as much you have the
two
um the two rings radiating out
presumably their zones that have been
earmarked that show
um the area that's likely to be affected
by shoot
which draw are you referring to Mr
bigman it's a figure three gladness
design and access statement plus map
now uh if you could just clarify what
the two rings are spreading out from
there that would
foreign
designations plan on local plan extract
is that correct figure three graduate
design and access statement plus map
um
do you um and this is within the design
and access statement is that correct
yeah
bear with me
I think probably what they are are ice
creams
um which show
um separation of distance over a spatial
errors and give you spatial context of
the plan that you're looking up but let
me just um double check
[Music]
figure three
you say figure 3.2
yes it's a public rights way
right
there's a page number
I think it's in the original design that
is a statement CD 1.05
um stage 10.
yeah
I got it designated plan and local plan
extracts is the title I think is that
what we're referring to
I think it must be
so the um
the the chapter that sits within is
about surrounding designations
um so the purpose of that plan is to
identify the sites and to put the site
within its surrounding context so the
the what you've identified the 0.5
kilometer the the one kilometer the five
kilometers of the circles that's what we
would call an isoch room so it's simply
the distance between the site the 0.5
kilometer the one kilometer and the 1.5
kilometer
and it's just to give you a kind of
spatial context of an understanding of
the site in the surrounding area
there's lots of assistance
okay
so this is my clarification what are the
the Rings what are they actually what
does each each line of the Ring show I'm
trying to get my
head around I'm not sure it's actually
I I it's it's merely just showing a
spatial distance
um it's not it's not a zone or a
designation or a local policy
designation it's it's just to give some
special contact to the overall uh plan
oh I see so each dotted line is is that
is the excited line half a kilometer or
less or is it yes half kilometer between
one
right I see
okay thank you
is that okay Mr Dickman okay
okay thank you uh I think that's
all the the comments I've got no further
questions on the mitigation
all these matters have to go away and
consider everything that's been said and
everything that's been provided in
writing as well so thank you for that uh
contribution discussion please which is
uh helpful to me as always can we just
move on to the next part of the
agenda for this morning's discussion and
in fact as we've been going for an hour
and a half and I've been uh
urging us all to have lots of breaks it
might well be let's just decide where
we're going to go next
and it might not be time just for a
short morning Comfort break Etc but when
we come back
if Miss Caldwell you could just briefly
run through
the other elements
uh in terms of bats was it barn owls as
well you wanted to discuss something
emotion barnards before
yes that was on your agenda yeah
yeah uh you can basically sort of
summarize that and we'll talk about
um
those aspects and then
including mitigation and then we'll do
the nitrogen disposition at the position
and then the other relevant matters uh
Net game and just concluding against the
policy requirements so if we can have a
short break now if we have is 11 minutes
going to be okay for everybody
okay we'll return we'll adjourn and
return at 11 15. thank you everybody
okay it's 11 15 so time to
[Music]
recommence the inquiry
um
let me just wait until my screen there
we go
thank you okay continuing uh on on
biodiversity matters uh
Miss Caldwell over to you as discussed
before so just sort of briefly sort of
summarize uh the further information and
where you stand in terms of the
appellance perspective on their barn
owls and also on bats please
thank you sir
um
as requested by pin the new advance to
the appeal week guided an additional
technical note on bar now
um which is
CD
8.06 for reference
um
essentially the situation is that the um
the conditions for supporting bar now on
site are very limited and we have
acknowledged that there's some potential
foraging habitat for barnout and on-site
and in The Wider landscape but this is
largely likely to be limited to post
Harvest when this build grains Etc which
can support small mammal species on
which the uh by now may predate
um we have not identified any potential
significant roosting or nesting habitat
within the site for bar now bar now or a
species that sort of barns or sometimes
trees with large cavities neither of
which occur within the site boundary
although we do accept that there may be
some opportunities within the wider
landscape
we did a desk study for bird records and
other biological records in 2019 and
updated that in 2021. we only received
four records of barn owls within a two
kilometer radius
um one of the closest records was from
back in 1994 that was in relation to
Margate Cemetery non-breeding
um and the closest record was actually
submitted by CSA uh ecologists ourselves
in January 2019
um which was a bird
recorded uh perched in a tree along
shutter down Road and that was recorded
in one of our winter bird services
so
we're aware of the presence of Bon Allen
in the local landscape but we've not
observed barn owl and foraging across
the site during any of our breeding bird
surveys nor any of the other wintering
bird survey visits which were extensive
between
November 2019 and February 2020 and no
incidental sightings
um of on our way during that survey work
undertaken between July and September
um or any of the reptile surveys which
require at least eight visits to the
site between August and September 2019.
so as such
um we do we concluded that the site is
not a significant resource for bar now
and whilst we accept uh they may be
present in the local landscape uh and uh
Crossing or origin on our site at
certain times of the year that there
will be no significant impact from our
proposals in addition to that the level
of landscaping proposed
um particularly the amount of
Wildflower and Tuskegee grassland
creation that will occur as part of the
Landscaping strategy and the mitigation
area will provide new significant
resources for bar now to be able to
forage across and as such uh no
significant adverse effects anticipated
I don't think there were any specific
points raised in relation to bar now but
um that's the information that we have
okay thank you I've got no questions on
barn owls
I don't think anybody else has any
points to raise at this stage so if you
move on to bats please
exactly sir
in relation to
swra have raised um
some concerns about the adequacy of the
assessment
and the presence or absence of roosting
bats
um shortfalls in our reporting and the
effectiveness of any mitigation that
we've suggested
um I have provided a full rebuttal to
the points raised within my proof of
evidence that's paragraph 6.17 onwards
um so I and I've had no rebuttal back
from swra to my proof
um however I'll run through the key
points in brief so that everybody's
aware of my position
um
in terms of survey effort the survey is
undertaken
um in some of 2019 were in line with the
back conservation
survey guidelines which is the industry
standard that we work to
um both in terms of
um the level of transect survey and
static monitoring and that was
undertaken
and the acceptability of these survey
method was confirmed by KCC in their
consultation response
um
this is detailed within uh six paragraph
6.19 to 6.2 a with my proof
um and in relation to Statics uh
paragraph 6.22
the value of uh the site for foraging
and commuting bats
um this site was assessed in terms of
the level of survey effort that we'd
have to undertake as low quality
um and low quality habitat in accordance
with the BCT survey guidelines includes
habitat which could be used by small
numbers of commuting bats which is gappy
hedgerows or unvegetated streams but
isolated I.E not very well connected to
the surrounding landscape via the high
quality habitat and
looking at an aerial photo of the site
so you'll see that it's a very open
arable landscape whilst there are some
gappy hedgerows and bands of scrub
um along some of the boundaries of the
site these are quite Limited in terms of
their extent and quality and whilst
there are some areas of suitable
foraging habitat with only Park and the
cemetery
um adjacent to the site there's there's
really no areas of significant high
quality habitat for bats in the
immediate landscape vicinity so that
informed our assessment of habitat
quality which
henceforth informed the level of survey
effort that we undertook
and I'm completely happy that um that is
in my professional judgment a
proportionate level of survey to
undertake
in terms of how we um valued the back
population set the site following our
survey work
um the level of bat activity was
considered to be very low across the
site both observed during the transit
surveys undertaking and the static
monitoring and we identified the site
was used by at least four species of
bats
um
dominated by Common hipster that are are
our most common and widespread that
species and common pedestrian activity
accounted for over 94 of calls recorded
during Transit surveys and over 98 of
calls recorded during a static
monitoring
we did also record low instances of
activity from soprano pipster Trail
um the presence of an Enthusiast
pipistro has been highlighted as a as a
rarer species but um I would like to
draw attention to the points I've made
in my proof about the very low level of
activity recorded from the species in
fact only four passes from this species
recorded during one of our transect
surveys and I think only three passes
recorded during any of the static
monitoring so very low incidents this is
a species that can migrate over large
distances and there's usually associated
with water features not present on our
site
um as such uh we undertook an evaluation
of the geographical level of importance
of
um that interests on our site we use the
methodology provided by Ray atal 2010
which doesn't form part of the official
BCT guidelines or Natural England
mitigation guidelines but is commonly
used by matter colleges within the
industry
um we used that methodology to assess
the importance of species was recorded
on the site
and that gave indicated that the site
was of local level importance for
commuting and foraging bats however
given the very low levels of activity
recorded and observed during our surveys
we thought that actually was like to be
less than local level and that takes
into account you know my own
professional experience of doing
hundreds of bad surveys across the
southeast you know during my career over
the last 15 years
in terms of roosting bats um swra have
highlighted the potential for roosting
bats to be present
um in trees within the Northwestern
corner of the site
um bw1 or G group g21 on the tree survey
we did identify the potential for bat
roof features to be present Within These
trees within
um chapter seven of the
um environmental statements and I
visited the site myself and I confirmed
that I would consider the suitability
for racing bats now
low suitability indicates ruse which
might be used by individual fat species
uh individual bats
um or you know they're of low quality
and of low incidence
moderate prfs and there might be more
than one feature
um or on a tree and also
um you know taken to the context the
surrounding habitat wood factory be in a
suitable location and habitat type for
bats to be roosting and that is
um
highlighted by the tree protection plan
and on the DW the dfp
um as shown on the landscape strategy
there'll be something for planting
um along there so the trees will be
protected and retained
um so no further survey required and in
fact in line with the BCT guidelines no
further survey is required at this
planning stage of trees with low Roost
potential anyway so we are compliant
with with the guidelines in that in that
in that
fact
however within the environmental
statement we have made some
recommendations about a sense of
lighting scheme to avoid any disturbance
effects on those trees or any other
boundary habitats used by foraging and
commuting bats to reduce any potential
disturbance and a condition has been
suggested to address that
[Music]
there were some points made in swt's
representations about the accuracy of
reporting and I reject those claims in
my proof of evidence paragraph 6.44 our
bat survey report clearly shows the
level of
um but activity recorded across the site
both in terms of volume of calls
recorded during Transit surveys and
um the locations where individual
species were recorded across the site
that can clearly be seen in the figures
um and as such uh we have identified
that there was a hotspot as it's been
referred to of activity along Sean Dane
Road
now that information is provided on the
basis of the transect survey information
and the static monitoring
the static monitoring positions were
located along John Day Road so that we
could specifically identify the level of
impact there where amendments to that
road layout will be made
we observed that
preferentially foraging around street
lights which were along Sunday Road
which leads to a skew in the data so
we did record more bat activity along
Sean Dane Road comparative to some other
locations on the site
there are some trees and vegetation
along chocolate Day Road which that I'm
using
but the level of activity is somewhat
skewed by bats repeatedly foraging
around Street lamps now
when you're looking at static data you
have to bear in mind that you've got no
visual cue so you don't know whether
that's uh a single bat repeatedly
foraging for an hour or two around a
particular feature or lots of fats
streaming along that's why we supplement
the transect surveys and during the
transit surveys
we observed repeated foraging by
individual bats hence informing our
assessment that um
the site was of a low level importance
for for bats in terms of number of bats
that were foraging across the site
um
sorry for interruptcy but just just
about on that point
the foraging hotspot Point has been
raised by
the residence group uh Westgate garlands
Action Group
about the loss in particular of
trees and hedgerows along shotendon Road
this is obviously in the master plan and
it's about an application and layout's
not a matter before us but the master
plan obviously shows dwellings you know
could be and might be proposed in that
location so there's a fair indication
that's possibly what might what might
happen you know subject to reserved
matters
but
your point there about
they raise the concern that there's a
loss of those trees and hedges which uh
would destroy vegetation which provides
the foraging hot spot in the words
is your point in response to that that
it's a foraging hot spot because the
bats are foraging around the street
lights rather than actually
using those
trees and hedges
so to clarify it's a bit of both so you
you know the bats are using shot and say
low
um as a bit of a flight Corridor because
there are two even hedgerows along that
road
but
the levels of that activity
um in terms of the pattern so this
repeated foraging activity by a low
number of individual bats is influenced
by the presence of street lights now I'm
not saying inferring that's a positive
thing because
street lights draw prey away from other
areas hence they draw some of the bat
species that are fairly light tolerant
like common paper trail towards those
features where they forage so
um I'm just saying that the presence of
street lights is skewing the data
slightly in terms of the patterns of
behavior
in terms of the impact along shopkinton
Road
some of that vegetation towards the
southern end of shotstone Road will be
retained and possibly buffered by new
landscape planting
this scheme although we have got a new
um roundabout Junction that is being
proposed a long shot down Road will be
boarded by nutrient hedgeroplantic so
similar habitat linkages which is one of
the requirements of fat P30 New Habitat
creation and habitat linkages will be
delivered as part of this scheme which
won't be dissimilar in location or type
to the existing
so
um in terms of concerns about impacts
along shot and Zayn Road it's not that
we haven't said that there won't be an
impact at the point of construction but
in the long term those resources will
remain and at any rate they're being
used by low numbers of bats at present
when you say in the long term what's how
many years would you put for it for the
replacement hedging in planting and
trees to get to the uh level where they
would provide a
similar benefit
well there will be a time lag I can't
comment on construction program at this
stage
um but time to Target condition for
um certain habitat types is clearly set
out within the biodiversity gain
assessment and uh you know for some
trees and hedgerows that might be
hedgers might be five years you know for
trees to reach to maturity depending on
what rootstock is used at the planting
stage you know could be 15 to 30 years
so yes possibly a log along lag time for
maturity of trees but that doesn't mean
that developing habitats won't have some
value for foraging bats
foreign
no problem sir um I'm nearly at the end
of the points there's just three other
points that were raised and addressed in
my
um
proof of evidence
um there was a point about requiring
further assessment of habitat for long
shot and down Road
um which has I've set out I do not
consider necessary or surveys were in
line with the BCT guidelines for survey
efforts
has been suggested by a swra that an
entomological survey should have been
undertaken
inferring that this would have informed
our assessment of
that interest across the site
um
and they reference an appeal that was
recently undertaken where where
undertaking entomological surveys was
one of the key issues the difference
with that site and our site is that the
habitats on our site are
common and widespread and not very
biodiversity
rich in terms of the opportunities that
they offer and I I wouldn't expect that
a site like this would require a
detailed entomological survey in terms
of uh assessment or invertebrates and in
terms of what such a survey could offer
in terms of our valuation of bat
activity well we've surveyed the bat
activity directly
and therefore we already have a measure
of of of what that interest is on the
site
um so I don't see what an entomological
survey would have added
um and at any rate it it to my
experience and knowledge is is not a
standard requirement for informing
assessment of that interest and impact
assessment for bats and storage at that
point
there was a brief point about assessment
of the impact of the scheme on protected
areas in relation to that
well the designated sites that we've
identified within the zone of influence
have not been designated for bats and
bats do not form a qualifying feature of
any of the European designations
and and therefore we haven't considered
uh the impact on bats in the context of
protected sites
and the final point was about mitigation
um concerns about the effectiveness of
the mitigation that we've proposed
um
I believe in terms of uh
lack of survey or potential roof sites
which I've already covered in the fact
that we don't anticipate any direct
impacts
um to potential roof sites and therefore
we have not proposed any specific
mitigation but we have proposed
mitigation in relation to a sensitive
lighting strategy which could be secured
by way of condition
um in addition to that in the particular
location of concern about Baton Rouge
centuries that's the Northwestern corner
of the site by Hearthstone Road
um
there is boundary planting buffer plants
who proposed there and none of the core
roads in terms of the current layout of
the site occur adjacent to those trees
and therefore comments about uh
headlights of cars Etc uh
um I would reject
um and at any rate lighting can be
secured but by condition anyway
um
we've also previously discussed the
homeowner information pack which could
also be secured by condition and would
provide guidance on
um security lighting that that residents
might want to provide on their own
housing you know clothing curtains at
night that sort of thing which I accept
uh
may not be enforceable in terms of the
actions that residents take but the
condition itself in terms of provision
of that education is
I think that's all the main points that
have been raised in relation to bats so
I will leave it there
thank you that's a helpful summary thank
you
um
Mrs Brown your hand is raised
would you like yes yes
thank you sir
I just want you to sort of mention that
there are three priority Woodlands
adjacent to the site
and ask if the bats travel between these
and the effect the trees will be
affected and if those feeds are removed
well that will though that will be
affected the travel between the adjacent
sites
and also given that um planet is very
low tree has the very low proportion of
of mature trees it seems wrong to remove
what we've what we've got where are the
Woodlands
is the one on the uh
it's on Magic Maps right right I don't
know how that is the one next door too
I'll just remember from my side visit
there's one sort of to the west of the
football ground
is that one of them
I believe so this probably might be able
to
confirm where they are
sorry sir
um
are you referring uh Mrs Brown to there
is a small area of Plantation Woodlands
of Hearts Dam Road sort of the north
west corner of our site
yeah I saw that on my site visit that's
opposite the Cricket Club I think isn't
it
yes I believe so
where were the locations of the other
two Woodlands there in some Woodland
um adjacent to shot in Dame Road uh
adjacent too yes yes that's right yes
yes
the northern
um sort of your leg of our of our parcel
north of shortly Day Road
and I assume you're referring to the
cemetery tied to the east
in terms of the third party yeah so
the purpose of our uh bat survey work
was to identify
with Bluetooth present on site the level
of activity and any key foraging and
Computing routes so that's what we set
out to discover so
um
the information provided in the back
survey report shows exactly where we
recorded individual species
and any
um hot spots shown on a heat map
um within that report
so
we have identified that bats are using
the boundary features likely for
foraging and commuting which made to a
certain extent
um
link to Woodland sites of site but those
linking habitats are largely being
retained as part of the scheme with the
exception of the section of shutdown
road that we've just spoken about
in terms of fats
um Crossing between retained boundaries
um of course they already have to cross
shuttle down road and deal with the
lighting there and
um
the situation won't be much dissimilar
when the roads realigned so
um
that should still be able to use and
disperse within the landscape largely as
they do at present
um does that help to answer your
questions
um
the other thing is is do can you pick up
if you can answer this me do um bats use
sonar of to bounce off trees for
navigation
they use sonar for for navigation and
for finding their prey and
um yes that's largely how they um
navigate the landscape
so um would the loss of the trees affect
their navigation
um
well bats will um both depending on the
back species as well they they will
travel over open Landscapes and not
necessarily using Sonar in the same way
and some bat species are species of um
clutter so Woodland bat species where
they use their sonar
on a much more intensive basis to be
able to navigate to not bump into that
tree or that leaf or what have you so I
think what you're asking is would
removal of the trees prevent the bats
um from traversing the landscape yes yes
um it's not so much that they wouldn't
be able to navigate it's just that bats
tend to preferentially navigate along
linear features
so that they can be sort of guided
through the landscape
I think that's what you're asking and
yes the majority of those linear
features
is part of this game
the trees the trees yes sorry that we're
not talking about linear features I'm
talking about Pedros nines of trees Etc
so for example along the Northwestern
boundary of the site that feature there
is being retained
as is the features between uh the qriket
club around Hearts down Road uh and the
sites as you come in we've got a
landscape buffer there with the studs
um so the layout has tried to buffer
those retained linear features where
possible and that should reduce any
impacts on the commuting bats
okay thank you
sorry and that was muted thank you for
that question Mrs Brown that response Mr
Dickman yes thank you um in fact thanks
to Jacqueline she was really going to
answer my uh she's asked my question
I think it's important one because
um in the report it does say it's near
of low quality however there are three
priority Woodlands uh close by
um that that the the the build
um
the question I wanted to ask is is how
far did the bats travel and how far is
it reasonable to to look in terms of
their Roost in habitat
shall I answer that yes yes
in terms of
um commuting from Roots
yeah yeah
so depending on the bat species
um
core sustenance zones as we call them
fairy between species
um for some species
um such as an Enthusiast pedestrial
um which commute over fairly large
distances those course assessments areas
are quite large
for um other species Woodland species
those those cool substances are much
lower but they'll still probably be
within one or two kilometers
um of a roost site so
um in terms of
um would the loss of our site impact
risk further refilled is that is that
what you're asking the only reason I'm
asking is um I wanted to ascertain how
fights reasonable to look for nesting
habitats or roosting uh the reason I ask
this is is because
um the other side of tivery woods when
you get to the tennis schools
um we've had a look around there and
there's quite a bit of nesting or we've
noticed uh nesting roosting from bats in
and around the railway arches and in the
uh embankments and I'm just wondering
whether you went that far given that
um it's within that area that they may
come forward you
so our survey work was restricted to the
boundaries of the application sites so
we didn't go any further
um in terms of looking at off-site
routes obviously we try and identify any
close by ruse in terms of the data
search that was undertaken
in terms of any key linkages between
potential off-site routes and habitats
on site we would pick those up during
the transect or static monitoring
surveys so if you look in the bat survey
report
um figure
7.52 of that report that clearly shows
all the points where we've recorded bats
and from that that's how we would pick
up the sort of patterns of activity and
dispersal and there's no clear
roots of dispersal that we've picked up
you know that would indicate uh an
off-site route that should really park
for example
in fact the levels of activity are
generally very low
um so if there was a significant ruse
close by to the site that we would need
to consider we would expect to pick up
indications of that through the bat
um serving work that we undertook
but it is considerable that within that
area the area they will travel that far
given the distance yes within yes but I
think the point the key Point here is
with the loss of any habitat resources
or impacts for Habitat resources on this
site result in an adverse impact to any
off-site roosts
and our conclusion is no
um
the main loss of habitat on our site is
the arable land and we didn't our
transect survey crisscrossed the arable
land we didn't just walk around the edge
and I think this was one of the points
raised in the in the bat survey rebuttal
that you provided
um I can provide a map attract map
because we GPS track all our routes as
well as the bat registrations that we
record and that clearly indicates that
we traveled
you know all over the site uh where
possible across the crop and um you know
we're not recording about activity in
the main arable crop areas and that
those are the main areas of the site
that will be impacted the boundary
vegetation will largely be retained
and with a sensitive lighting strategy
to try and avoid any disturbance if that
retained habitat or new habitats to be
created which are extensive I might add
um we should be able to avoid any
disturbance impacts
two bats that are using the site
thank you and finally just a question to
yourself sir really and it's really just
to highlight that indeed as far as we're
aware uh the three uh areas of priority
Woodland weren't highlighted they're all
magic match and I do know that Gremlins
have used magic mats and really it's
just posing the question why won't they
highlighted originally
thank you sir
would you like me to respond is it yours
sorry I'm muted uh yeah that last point
was called where you'd like to read
through the response please
the priority habitats
um were off-site so no direct impacts to
those priority habitats are anticipated
so they weren't explicitly identified
within our reports and we do use magic
Maps you're right to check for such
features including designated sites also
including the record search response
that we get from
um Can a Medway biological Vehicle
Center which highlights Norton statutory
designations
um and important habitat so
we have taken that into consideration in
in our assessment but
um none of those features occur uh you
know within the within the Impact Zone
uh predicted by our site
um we did
uh provide a description of the wider
landscape in terms of habitat for bats
within our report
um and um you know overall the landscape
is not particularly rich in habitat
suitable for bats but we did highlight
those adjacent Woodlands the cemetery
Etc
okay
thank you
thank you thank you both uh before we
move on
this is brown your hand is up
thank you sir
um
I just wanted to ask um what will the
impact of construction have on Dutch
foraging
are you concerned there about lighting
impacts perhaps no I'm I'm you know sort
of I'm concerned about the disturbance
from the um because action you know
in terms of vibration or yes yes
activity and analyty actually as well
yes
well in terms of activities on site
vibrations
Etc
we haven't identified
um
any roofs locations on or adjacent to
the site
um and therefore we wouldn't expect that
there would be any significant impacts
at the construction stage
um bearing in mind
um with regards to lighting that
um construction activities that require
lighting are largely likely to be
happening in the winter period when bats
are generally hibernating now they do
come out of hibernation to to drink and
feed occasionally but by and large
um the activity from back to respecting
across this site will be in the summer
months and there would be no
construction impacts in the evening when
those bats would be active and therefore
no lighting disturbance happening at
that point
okay thank you
okay thank you very thank you everyone
for those points and questions and those
responses from this Caldwell
okay I think that deals with
once again things for me to go away and
consider if we can go to our item e
effects on nitrogen deposition upon
chalk whole Farm roadside Nature Reserve
I don't think this has been particularly
raised by
um
interested parties but I just wanted
just clarification
from the appellant on what the effect is
uh and its level of effect can it be
mitigated or has it been mitigated and
how that is
incorporated into this sort of overall
conclusions on effects uh obviously
again relating back to the to the
relevant policies
thank you sir I'll I'll just provide a
bit of information about um Chuck Hall
Farm roadside Nature Reserve
um this is a local designation
um and it's non-statury and as such uh
we would value that at a county level of
importance in terms of geographic
importance
um it comprises about 280 meters of
roadside Verge along flat road which is
about 0.4 kilometers south of the site
um branching off from manston Road
um the site has been designated for the
nutrient pool grafland that it supports
and in particular World Clary which is a
species of Nutri poor soils and um
scarce in Kent
um in terms of um impacts to this road
in terms of the road itself
um
it was scoped out of the traffic
assessment because this road receives
very low
um traffic flow that present and it
wasn't anticipated that traffic flows
along this road would increase
significantly as a result of the
development
because it doesn't really go in anywhere
it's a access only road to the
properties further down Flat Road it's a
very narrow Lane it has a restriction of
6.6 foot
um in terms of access and has various
speed bumps passing places Etc along it
however manston Road at points it's
close to the nature roadside Nature
Reserve
um
branching off in a sort of triangular
formation and
um being about 165 meters away from the
roadside Nature Reserve as its furthest
point
with arable land in in between Flat Road
and Manson Road
now Natural England guidelines for
thinking about the effects of vehicle
emissions
um on habitats in terms of habitat
degradation from nitrogen deposition for
example guides us to
um think about traffic related impacts
on roads within 200 meters of a
designation and this is typically
um
in relation to European designations but
here we've applied that same methodology
to this local designation
and
looking at the figures presented in the
traffic assessment which was undertaken
on the basis of 550 dwellings
um so a buffer on the 450 currently
being proposed
um future traffic flows are above the
1000 aadt annualized average daily trips
um modeled for manston Road and that
threshold of a thousand
um is what the Natural England
guidelines identifies as a threshold so
where you've got an increase of above
1000 ADT you may you may expect a
significant effect
the next stage would typically be to
look at critical loadings for the
habitat type
um that's concerned now that information
is really only available in relation to
sssi designations
um so we don't have that information in
relation to the roadside Nature Reserve
hence our initial conclusion is that
there could be a likely significant
effect
as a result of nitrogen deposition on
the roadside Nature Reserve
it could affect the whole length of the
nature reserve designation and the
the level of importance of that
designation says County and therefore we
concluded a County uh level
significant effect
um
now in terms of mitigation
that's difficult we can't mitigate for
that because
um those emissions will happen and that
deposition could occur
however we have proposed by way of
compensation creation of new calcareous
grass and habitat which is a habitat of
principal importance and scarce
in Kent we've proposed that within the
landscape strategy for the development
we have proposed
0.16 hectares of calcareous grassland
creation
and whilst we don't know the exact size
of the roadside Nature Reserve that's
not provided in the citation we know
it's 280 meters long we know from
looking at
uh you know Google Maps and street views
and things like that that verges
unlikely to be more than five meters
wide
which would give 0.14 hectares roughly
in terms of that so we are seeking to
create more calcareous grassland than we
would potentially be impacting
and that
um that assessment is you know quite a
precautionary basis really
um also given the fact that nitrogen
deposition affects diminish with
distance so whilst at the Northern end
of the roadside Nature Reserve we're
quite close to Manson Road by the time
you get to the southern end of the
reserve 165 meters away and therefore
any effects of nitrogen deposition may
be expected to diminish so
um
I hope in a nutshell that explains sort
of rationale in terms of the conclusions
in the US
because we're proposing compensation
rather than mitigation on residual
effects which are assessed after
mitigation are still that there would be
an adverse effect at the county level
however we then propose this
compensation in terms of New Habitat
creation on site which will help to
elaborate those adverse effects
thank you sir
thank you so just in terms of the
overall conclusion does that mean
there's any significant effect that's
carried over into the final if you like
ecology sort of balance or ecology
waking or weighing up of of impacts
um
or is it your argument argument that
there'd be no there'll be no significant
effect because of the compensation
provided
yes exactly
so
um there is
residual effects are Quantified
um after the mitigation stage and I mean
it's semantics but really we're
presenting proposing compensation so
um
in you know in es structure terms
um ecia we consider compensation
after the residual effects stage
so that is why it's presented like that
in the environmental statement but yes I
would agree that we're over providing
um in terms of the amount of nuclear
carriers grasslands that we will be
creating
and
we don't know if we're going to lose all
that you know the value of that
grassland on the roadside Nature Reserve
or not what we've concluded is there
could be a likely significant effect
that could be a reduction of the quality
of that grassland
I doubt very much we're going to lose
all the value of that grassland and
therefore the level of compensation
we're providing is a is a buffer on on
top of that
okay
okay I understand thank you Mr
Livingstone
I've receive it for the council's point
of view you're not raised objection to
this that you're in agreement are you
what's being said and that there's no if
you like sort of there's no significant
fact to carry over to be considered as
part of the the policy
no it was our determination that agreed
with the provisions that were made on
site
okay thank you and
uh Mr Dickman surprise me again really
it's just the point of accuracy and that
is uh Fleet Road where uh chalk Hall
Farm is situated isn't actually an
access only Road it is a through Road
and and it's quite important to make
that point because at busy times uh
manston Road changes very very quickly
particularly during the summer months
and times when people are using the tip
and it's often used as a Rat Run
um if indeed it's like that so cars do
pass up and down there
um it is it is a through Road I've been
a very local resident I tend to try not
to use it
um you're correcting your uh your
analysis and it's very narrow but it is
a through Road
okay thank you for that
clarification
um
I've got another hand up from
Miss Caldwell I don't think I've uh
sorry sorry
[Music]
it's very close to lunch
um
I've just going to briefly respond on
that last time going up that confused me
sorry
um yeah just on that last point for Miss
Mr Dickman
um our assessment obviously has
um scoped in a potential impact uh
on the roadside Nature Reserve
um whether or not there was any traffic
down Fleet Road or not because of its
proximity to to manston Road
um and whilst there is traffic down
Fleet Road
um the transport consultant has
indicated that even with
a minor increase that might be expected
from the proposed of element we wouldn't
get anywhere near that threshold of an
increase of a thousand aadt
um along that road so
um that's just a point of clarification
okay thank you
for that so moving on to uh
just overall sort of conclusions briefly
on relevant policy requirements
obviously that's really for me to do
rather than anybody else in my decision
but before we do that do you want to
just go through because obviously
there's a further documentary being
provided I think with the uh proves in
December on the net biodiversity game
which of course is one of the policy
requirements could you just again just
Briefly summarize that for everybody
please
yes sir so um a biodiversity Net game
assessment has been undertaken using
um uh definitely metric 3.0 which at
present is the current metric
um that was introduced
um
initially the back end of 2019 but this
new metric came out
um uh middle of last summer
um
this looks at a measurable
um index of
um gains or losses of habitat Types on
site so it takes the Baseline habitat
information and that we have about the
site so
um the area habitat type and habitat
quality or condition of the habitats
currently present on site and sets that
against the habitats that will be
delivered or could be delivered
um as part of the proposed scheme so
we've faced our calculations on the most
recent version of the landscape strategy
plan which demonstrates the scope to
deliver these types of habitats on site
um
in terms of the habitat types um
that will be created on site
um we've got some quite significant
areas of modified grassland 3.6 hectares
um which is largely in the amenity areas
so we've assumed that that would be in
poor condition
um and that gets a lower weighting in
the metric
for areas of wildlife grassland position
provision or areas specifically where um
we'll be safeguarding for biodiversity
um we've assumed a neutral or calcareous
grassland habitat provision and that the
condition of that should be able to be
greater than poor because
um we'll be specifically managing it to
improve and Achieve good good habitat
quality in those areas
um in addition to Grassland it takes
account um scrub and Thicket planting
and
new woodland or structural tree planting
and hedgerows Street trees
Etc
the outcome of the assessment is that
this game has got the scope to deliver
at 7.45 net gain in terms of habitat
units and we also look at linear
features so hedgerows tree lines Etc as
a separate part of the metric and um
there'll be significant provision of
those with a 54 gain in hetero units
calculated
um
as such this scheme uh demonstrates that
we'll be delivering a measurable net
gain for biodiversity
um as part of the report there's also an
assessment of the functional value of
the habitat types that will be delivered
as part of the scheme
um so that we can ensure that we're
delivering the right types of habitats
in the right places
um there's also a
trading summary that's provided as part
of that report to make sure that we are
um compensating any habitat losses with
reprovisioning of the same types of
habitat where we've got distinctive
habitats and that trading summary has
been satisfied as part of the assessment
um in addition to the measurable net
gain elements in terms of biodiversity
units
um you know we've suggested a number of
other enhancements
um which are drawn out in some of the
draft conditions so nest boxes
um permeability of
um fencing for hedgehogs
um
the type of new planting that can be
provided in terms of seed and Berry
production for breeding birds Etc
um so I think that gives gives everybody
hopefully a a a good summary of Where
we've got to with the Net game
thank you there's a question from me in
terms of the
what we talked about earlier in terms of
the effects on breeding birds how is
that factored into the uh biodiversity
gain calculations
calculations are specific
s classifications for Habitat types
so we're specifically looking at habitat
type and how distinctive that habitat is
so for example arable habitats got a
very low distinctiveness
and a low
um waiting in the metric versus
um richer habitat types like hedgerows
and wooden planting and Native grassland
creation which are more distinctive
so the metric really only looks at the
habitat type and the condition it
doesn't take into account
um specific species requirements but
that's why it's part of the biodiversity
Net game report we also look at
functionality of those habitats so that
we can make sure that we're creating the
right types of habitats to
mitigate enhance
resources for for the species that we
have on site so that would include green
birds
okay thank you and Miss Livingston again
I'm assuming from the sort of your uh
reading your responses that the council
has accepted the biodiversity net gains
information provided by the appellant is
that the
am I right and assuming that
yeah so it was an issue that was looked
at within the the sub previous landscape
strategy uh that was put in during the
application in terms of the the
enhancements from that uh Parable land
value at the moment uh with the habitats
that are being created with the
semi-natural habitators including the
grassland and and the hedgerows that um
so there's no point of of dispute
specifically with regards to
um overall net gain from The Proposal
okay
thank you
Mrs uh Brown you've got your hand up
would you like to comments at this point
Thank you thank you sir
um I just I just wanted to ask about
um the provision for looking after newly
planted trees and hedgerows and and the
management of them is that it is that um
been considered considered in what
you'll pick what you're proposing
okay it's not a complete register to
this topic but uh if you could respond
to that in this call them at this point
yes sure
um
well in terms of biodiversity Net game
and the environment bill will require
any habitat delivery an enhancement to
be secured for a minimum 30 years
um so there is provision within that
bill for that in terms of this
application
um we have proposed that there will be a
bespoke Landscape Management plan to
cover the detail for management
of those areas and there will also be
detailed planting plans provided to set
out exactly what seed mixes trees Etc
planted where draft conditions have been
provided to secure those elements
um to be provided in advance of any
reserve each Reserve matters stage
um so each phase of the development so
there is provision there
um and that will be secured at the
detailed planning stage
okay thank you
a responsibility for overall money
ongoing management once the scheme's
been implemented so things such as we
were talking before about the bird
protection area and the the fences who
would have who would be you know using a
perhaps an example how would if somebody
was to defense was to blow down or I
don't know fell down or just whatever in
15 years time just disintegrated who
would be responsible for maintaining it
in perpetuity
foreign
I think my colleague Chris Ball wants to
interject at this moment may be helpful
at this point sir um we'll come to this
as part of the the obligation session
but within um the draft obligation are
Open Space Management Company Provisions
so that they would be um taken forward
by a management company for the life of
the development
okay thank you and as you say we can
pick that up if need be further in the
uh
uh I think obligation session okay thank
you okay that's I think all I want to
hear on biodiversity net gain uh Mr
Dickman sorry sir I I thought I'd put my
hand up just very quickly and going back
to
um the notion that arable land and I do
take the point isn't necessarily uh that
important to many of the nesting Birds
the only is it's important to the
certainly the three birds that are on
the uh Red List uh they do like open
land they do like
um arable land
um and I wonder if that's actually
weighted in terms of uh looking at the
net again and similarly we we do know
although it wasn't highlighted or you
you did see a lot of evidence we do know
the golden plumber uses that functional
land which is Farmland uh it's a winter
over to rest um has that all been into
the Net game
Miss Caldwell
I might respond on that point
in terms of the Net game calculations
these calculations the measurable Net
game is purely on habitat type and
condition so the methodology for that
assessment which is a standard
methodology put forward by Natural
England and defra doesn't take account
of species presence or requirements so
in terms of the percentages that we're
quoting no there's no waiting in the
metric for that
however obviously we have taken account
of that in terms of our impact
assessment as part of the environmental
statement and that is the way
um that these things are dealt with in
terms of net gain so
um the numbers the measurable bit within
the metric doesn't take account of it
but our wider assessment within the Net
game report on function of functionality
of the habitats it does and the impacts
to Farmland Birds obviously specifically
addressed elsewhere
okay thank you and thank you for that
question Mr Dickman okay
um
so
just in terms of conclusions against
relevant policy
requirements and going back to policy
sp30 that we considered before and just
one clarification or question from
me honestly on the uh goes back again to
the breeding birds in the statement of
common ground
it says the subject to these measures
being implemented these the mitigation
measures for the breeding birds residual
impacts to key species are significant
at no more than local level and
beneficial effects for other species are
anticipated at the site level we
discussed before what is meant by a
local level but does that Center subject
to these measures being implemented
residual impacts to key species are
significant at no more than local level
that still means does it that there'll
be significant
impacts to be considered when we when I
consider sp30 is that what that is
saying or have I misread that
I believe that within our
um final conclusions of our updated ES
that taking account of the mitigation in
an enhancement compensation measures
proposed that there would be no likely
significant effects in relation to
Skylark
and at most a site level adverse effect
in terms of great Partridge and corn
bunting
is that going back to sp30 E
is that still effect going to be sorry
sp30c
and the overall wording of the policy
included that last sentence of the
policy about if it resources significant
harm to biodiversity
geodiversity assets which cannot be
mitigated or as last resort compensated
for does that mean that
that would still if you like count
against
that part of the policy because it's is
the effects is the effect still
significant
there is an effect
but at less the local level
so we have reduced the level of fact
um as far as we think
it's possible
um to be compliant with that part of the
policy
is that level significant or is it
from that local level but in terms of
going back to the policy which doesn't
talk about local level counter level it
talks about significant effects would
that would that affect that residual
effect still be significant we have
concluded a significant effect at the
site level for those two species
okay Mr Livingston is that how the
council sees it as well
uh I think given the given the
information that that's obviously come
forward in light of the inquiry
um I think it is it is a case that you
know it's acknowledged that obviously
there is mitigation in place here that's
being put forward
um and
in terms of whether or not it you know
it results in the the word if we go to
that wording specifically uh planning
pushing will not be granted development
if it results in significant
biodiversity which cannot be adequately
mitigated
obviously the the panel that's put
forward mitigation which is suggesting
it would be you know adequately
mitigating on a planning balance point
when looking at the policy as a whole
and obviously this is obviously what we
did in the determination when it went to
planning committee was obviously whilst
you have the Farmland bird issue you
also have the other issues to do with
biodiversity on this site and the
obviously improvements that are being
made in other in other ways as well so
it's the for the planning side of things
rather than the sort of es judgment if
you see what I mean
um it's the the balancing up as led you
know in the view of the council to not
result in significant harm
okay
thank you and
it might be I see both it's called Mr
Boss I was going to sort of say this
might this might be one area which might
sort of spill over into the session this
afternoon or tomorrow morning on on on
planning matters but Mr ball did you
have anything he wanted to say at this
point on this
um it was largely to reinforce the point
that that Mr Livingston made and I think
when we're talking about scale of harm
um in this instance we're dealing with
an eia development and
the the harms that this Caldwell has
identified relate to significance in
terms of eia
um in this instance we're dealing with
uh policy sp30 and and my read of that
significant harm is a different scale of
harm we are talking about planning harm
arising from the developments
um when we look at planning policy
obviously in this instance we are
looking at a site that has been assessed
through the local plan process and
allocated and as part of that site
assessment process the council sifted
sites to remove those which would result
in the highest level of ecological
impact as part of their site assessment
and allocate those that resulted in the
lowest amounts of ecological impact
um and I think also within the policy
itself we can't just focus on the final
sentence there's also the point that uh
Miss Caldwell draw on early about
creation of linkages between the sites
so in this instance
um she referred to back linkages uh
there's also the Clause at um 0.2 which
refers to creation of wildlife habitats
where appropriate by including
opportunities for increasing
biodiversity in the design of the new
developments which have been
incorporated into these proposals so I
think I'm hesitant to use the term now
but when you take things in the planning
balance you have to consider the harm
overall whether that has been mitigated
and in this instance the caveats at the
end of the policy allows you to consider
mitigation and compensation as part of
the overall test as to compliance to the
policy
okay thank you
for that clarification and solution
thank you and thank you Miss Caldwell
first before was called Mr Dickman your
hand is up again
you're on me to think
you're on mute Mr Dickman
I think you're on mute
yes it's just
um going back to that notion of
mitigating to uh and and what worries me
is that doesn't appear to be any
mitigation for the birds on the Red List
the very nature that it will push them
out from the fields into other fields
where uh quite clearly there will be
recreational uh movement through those
fields it just seems to me that there
hasn't been any mitigation for the three
birds on the Red List well I know it's
only at local level it is of local
importance okay and I understand that
point from your your previous
submissions today as well so I yeah I
have yeah I absolutely appreciate that
and I'll take that into consideration
um Coldwell
it was just a final Point really to well
to largely echo my colleague Chris
Ball's comments there about all the
other elements of sp30 which I think
he's already been through so I won't
repeat but in terms of the mitigating
against the loss of farming bird
habitats
um we've covered the points about the
armland red list species of open land
but of course in terms of the other red
listed Farmland bird species which use
heterocyclitis trees Etc there will be a
large positive increase in the types of
habitats that those species use so I
think when we're talking about balance
we have to bear that in mind that there
will be some significant benefits for
other vulnerable species
okay thank you and I think finally on
this biodiversity issue Mr Williams
I think
thank you sir it's just a short point
for me we can pick this up with Mr Paul
but in support of I think what Mr
Livingston and Mr ball were saying you
may want to note the similarity between
policy SP 30 in requiring first of all a
net gain for biodiversity assets and
then applying the mitigation hierarchy
um by reference to avoid mitigate and
compensate effectively reflects the nppf
at paragraph 179b
and paragraph 180 and so the use of the
language significant in that context is
significant in planning policy terms
rather than in eia terms
thank you I understand that thank you
okay I think that
brings us to the end of the biodiversity
uh discussion so thank you for
everyone's submissions and comments and
questions in that regard uh
to send the appellant that was all very
helpful to me thank you and I think it's
important to add as issues I know the
council hasn't objected on the what
we've been discussing today but I think
in the light of the concerns expressed
by residents that was a worthwhile and
useful discussion so thank you all
right it's 12 26 so if we can
move
on to the next
item on the agenda which is Heritage I
again this is not a matter which has
been raised by
the council but it's not a significant
matter that has been raised by
interested parties that have been
passing references to it the reason I
put it on the agenda were that obviously
as a decision maker I've got a statue of
Duty to assess impacts on designated
Heritage assets which obviously there
are several in this case I've got uh
some helpful submissions uh from the
main parties and a statement of Common
Ground so it's just I I'm expecting I
was in two minds where I'm not just to
deal with this on the basis of the
written submissions as well but I
thought I will go for it in terms of an
informal informal but a round table
discussion but I think it can be taken
quite quickly and I think we can finish
certainly by one o'clock so
just give me one minute I'm going to
turn off my camera while I get the
relevant documents in front of me and
then we can we can start going through
the uh agenda uh which I've said set out
previously so I'll be I'll disturb my
camera and I'll return in a couple of
moments
thank you
right thank you for waiting
uh so
turning to the agenda first of all just
to get a clarification of
or confirmation of who wishes to
contribute to this discussion
thank you sir can I introduce Mrs Mira
who's here and also is that I you've got
the documents
um have you received the Heritage
position statement that Mrs Mira
produced
uh yes I have in fact that was going to
be sort of my that's right in front of
me because that was going to be sort of
what was going to sort of lead me
through the discussion from my point of
view to be honest and I've got also a
helpful uh
map that's been provided presumably by
Mrs Vera which sets out the location of
the relevant Heritage assets as well
there's a Heritage statement of coral
ground as well yeah largely reflects the
position statement but it goes a bit
further obviously in setting out the
council's position as well yeah okay
thank you and I at my site visit last uh
when was it last Thursday I
went to see as far as I possibly could
including a walk through the cemetery uh
the Heritage assets that have been
referred to although I would add the
caveat that
the two that I couldn't really see
because I was viewing from public places
were
I didn't see much at all of the Railway
uh convalescent home the grade two
listed building because that was largely
hidden and I'd go down the driveway so
uh yeah I didn't really see much of that
so I'm going on what I've read about
that and I sort of got I think what I
got I think glimpses of what I presumed
was a shot and Dane farmhouse
because I walked down that footpath
which goes between the two roads it died
in the footpath which cuts across the
corner past the Cricket Club
um and I also observed in the distance
and got a bit more closer to the uh
the Parish church of Saint John the
Baptist the grade one listed building uh
and I could observe that from the site
so I've got I think I've got a pretty
good sort of uh view of what I had to
see apart from those those caveats
so okay any interested party or rule six
would like to take part in this
discussion
okay
thank you and obviously we've got Mr so
that I will obviously Reserve any
comments at the end of the day that's
fine that's fine Mr Dickman thank you
okay
um
so
the less Mrs Mary wanted to sort of say
any sort of broad introductory sort of
comments which I'm happy to let you do
if you want I was going to propose that
we went to look at look through the four
designated Heritage assets that I've
listed a b c and d in my agenda
are you happy we go straight to those or
was there anything sort of you wanted to
say as just a wave introduction from
your point of view no I'm happy with
that sir I think you have have the um
all the background you need in the
Heritage assessment and statement of
Common Ground did you um need my um
qualifications and experience at all or
if you've got that I think I probably
have those in the proof I do I've got
them not in your proof in your position
statement I've got those yeah yeah
that's absolutely fine I'll take that as
being read yeah thank you
so the first one
uh is John's
cemetery and just for my clarification
because I did walk through the cemetery
and uh several interesting buildings and
monuments Etc in there which I saw but
as I understand it in terms of the
impacts of the scheme it's agreed that
there'd be it was described as
negligible harm to the significance of
the grade two listed Gates and gate
piers and section of curved curved wall
and just so I'm absolutely clear on this
there's two there are two gates into the
cemetery to the road from Cemetery to
the road but the ones that are be
referred to I presume from the drawing
you provided of the ones to the north
the northern set rather than the
southern set that's right sir do you
have um
figure three of the Heritage assessment
yeah I'm looking at that now yeah yes so
the northern set which I've labeled lb5
are the listed Gates and you're right
there's a another pair further down
which are later in date and are not
designated right those aren't those and
they said okay uh
foreign
setting of the uh
those Gates how sort of far would that
setting
um I'm trying to use the right word uh
expanding to the side it's not the right
word but I think you know what I mean
I do and it's with Heritage setting we
don't tend to think in terms of fixed
distances we kind of we think about
what's important so
for the listed Gates the key aspect of
its setting is the Symmetry
um and you think about where you
experience those gates from being the
road and the cemetery itself
agricultural land within the site which
you can see from the vicinity of the
gates is is part of its setting
um from which you experience the gates
but the contribution it makes to
significance is lesser because it's
um
setting where virtual proximity rather
than historic function or relationship
okay
thank you and
it's agreed between the council and the
yourselves that the harm would be
negligible
and but of course that still amounts to
less than substantial harm
in the words of the uh the framework uh
okay so that's one thing to me and I'll
look at these again when I do the site
visits the accompanied site visit of
course
um
and it's agreed there's no harm to other
designated Heritage assets within the
cemetery
that's correct yes yes so the other
assets are the Chapels and various
memorials which are within the cemetery
okay thank you okay I think that's all I
need to ask because I say a lot of this
is these assessments being provided Etc
so I don't want to sort of Have To Tread
over over ground on a matter which
doesn't seem to be a particular sort of
great matter of disagreement between the
the parties albeit I've still got to
make it my own mind obviously okay
um so the next one is
um
oh
The Farmhouse shotton Dane Farmhouse and
the impacts on this one are agreed I
think it's being less than substantial
again towards the lower end of this harm
Spectrum uh okay that's helpful thank
you
could you just sort of just
expand upon uh your assessment of that
of that of that harm in the context of
the scheme being proposed yes of course
I mean when we looked at chosen down
Farmhouse of course we were mindful of
the fact that it's a farmhouse sitting
within agricultural land but if you've
noticed the indivisibility is really
very limited uh even in winter
and the land within the site doesn't
appear to actually have been farmed from
The Farmhouse except for part of the
northern section
um and to ascertain that we looked at
the historic records including the ties
survey of the mid-19th century to the
majority of the adjacent land was under
secret occupancy and ownership at that
time
it's also undergone fairly substantial
degrees of change there were brickworks
nearby historically and its current
situation in these large post-war fields
so we thought about to what extent the
land within the site contributes to the
significance of The Farmhouse and while
it's adjacent and while it's
agricultural it's actually quite Limited
and there are certain mitigation
measures in place including some
adjacent open space to the West
and taking these factors into account I
concluded that the harm was less than
substantial at the lower end
okay you touched on to my next question
there in terms of the mitigation that's
proposed uh
uh so this is shown on the master plan
I'm just looking at the master plan
um
is the space you refer to
to the
Northwest of The Farmhouse or west of
the Farmhouse to the worst one I'm
looking at the parameters plan version C
the ability mode just get the
master plan
would that be
um CSF CSA reference 5230 106. okay I've
got
I think I've got that hair printed out
uh yeah
um I'm looking at the wrong document
there what reference is yours apologies
yeah I'm looking at the parameter plan
um
he clearly shows it actually it shows it
more clearly than on the actual
illustrator master plan as to where the
open space is so I think I've
seen what I need to see in that regard
and that's to the west of The Farmhouse
whereas to the south of The Farmhouse
there is an area of what would be
proposed as built development in the
master plan
what's the reasoning for providing the
open space to the in terms of mitigation
for this effect on on that side rather
than is also on the to the south of The
Farmhouse
yes I mean partly
the land was to the Northwest rather
than to the Southwest
um and to the South Southwest you've got
um fairly dense planting
okay
and when I do the air site visit on
whenever it is next week
can I get a sort of
will there be opportunity I hope for the
opportunity because I've sort of done
all the public footpaths have to do as a
game of course and it's always useful to
do them again after I've heard all the
evidence at an inquiry or a hearing but
the uh is it possible to actually
presumably get into that part of the
site and sort of walk down that boundary
to have a look at that relationship
between the agricultural Landers
existing in The Farmhouse
I presumably you might need the Wellies
on but is that
yeah I mean you can walk um along within
the site yes um actually you don't get a
very good appreciation of The Farmhouse
it's quite limited okay well I'd still
like to if that's the case I think
that's still the helpful but to see if I
can be added to the list of things on my
uh site visit schedule that uh I'd like
to be drawn up but then that'll be
helpful I mean in general actually it
probably would be useful as a general
point if I could
walk Round the perimeter inside the site
on the perimeter if that is possible
because that's what I've obviously not
done so far so I think that would be
something it's probably quite a lengthy
walk but it's not you know
um
so I might suggest probably the
Northwestern boundary Which is higher
ground is probably where you'll get a
better sense of use as a farmhouse yeah
okay okay well I can look at that
further at the side was it okay thank
you
um
okay that's I think all I want to ask
about
The Farmhouse
um
just this thing about towards the lower
end of the harm Spectrum I know
it's not really a requirement to be a
ppf just to look at spectrums but
invariably uh parties do these days but
towards the lower end of this uh harm
Spectrum so if the harm spectrum is from
naught to 100 whereabouts is towards the
Leverage
um
10 right you know sort of
um yes I don't I haven't really thought
about it on a not to 100 scale I have to
admit but um low end yeah okay thank you
um okay so moving on to C and this is
the railway convalescent home
grade two listed building as I said I
from the street it's really difficult
you can sort of see down the driveway
but that that is it I don't think I even
I might have got one glimpse of the
actual building I don't know again if
it's possible to see that more clearly
from any other
Vantage points
uh
Mr Livingstone Johnson just just on that
point of Advantage points um I think as
you travel uh west to east on Hearts
down Road effectively down the hill
before you then go back up the hill to
coffin house Corner traffic lights what
you do see is is some appreciation of
the the very top of that building right
um
but again so I just wonder whether or
not that's something to again factor
into the site visit obviously that's
something you may well be it may be more
visible at this time of year as well
good care of course yeah yeah okay yeah
I'm happy to uh I'm happy to do that
um
okay
and for this building
we've got negligible harm at most
which I presume is sort of even lower
than the negligible harm for the uh the
gates I'm presuming the way that's been
framed anyway but still less than
substantial so still something to be
sort of carried in the in the in the
balance of course
um
I think other than seeing it I've got
nothing else to really ask about that
and this is anything you want to
say in that regard
no I think it's in my assessment but the
intervisibility again is very limited I
think possibly
views from the upper floors in Winter
um but nothing beyond that that I've
noticed
okay
okay and so those are
in terms of the
position of both parties
those three
assets are the only assets where there
would be
some whether it be negligible up to uh
the lower end of harm Spectrum for The
Farmhouse where they'd be actually harm
to the setting of designated Heritage
assets
okay I put down
also on the agenda
the Parish church of Saint John the
Baptist
uh
possibly because of the importance of
this is a grade one listed building
so could you just describe and I did see
this on the so from the site I walked up
the footpath that goes
from the uh it's on my on my OS map it's
the area called as the 20s
which is a little there's a row of
terrorist properties and various other
properties that it goes up to a more
more sort of modern the corner of more
of more modern area developments anyway
it was a good vantage point for which I
could clearly see I think I saw the uh
the church at that vantage point I may
be wrong but I think it was the Spire
rather but could you just sort of just
describe sort of briefly what the sort
of that your appraisal in terms of the
development on the site on that grade
one listed building
wide parts surrounding landscape and
views we might pick out in particular
are views from historic approaches and
for this site it's the view the view
from shotton down Road although it has
um has some realignment historically
um we identified as potentially
contributing to the significance of the
church the way the open space is laid
out does allow for a retention of a sort
of narrow view towards the Spire within
the proposed scheme and on that basis
while you might find a reduction from
from small areas I don't consider there
to be any harms the overall significance
of the church
it has the master plan sort of developed
in any way in order to
get to that position
I'm a mindful there was a channeled view
along from shotendun Road
um I think it's also mentioned in the
landscape assessment
okay I'll have a another look at that
view
on my site visit okay
thank you
okay anything further anybody wants to
add in terms of those
designated assets
okay
um
[Music]
now any other effects this is part three
or point three any other effects and or
issues related to designated online
designated Heritage assets including
archeology are there any other sort of
non-tequity assignment archeology
are there any other non-designated
assets that could possibly be affected
um
so yes uh St John's Cemetery or Margate
Cemetery itself separate to the listed
buildings is a non-designated Heritage
asset and I have a system negligible
harm
so that's what the temperature as a
whole sort of as opposed to individual
sort of designated features within it
exactly yes as a landscape or designed
landscape
foreign
okay and any further ones
no no I've identified any harm to no
other than the archaeological resource
for occur
and tell it to archeology
again I think it's fairly clear in some
of the written submissions but you could
just give a brief overview now for the
for the benefit of the inquiry in terms
of the approach taken
yes of course so we assessed the
archaeological resource through desk
space assessment geophysical survey and
trial trench evaluation
and this identified an area of
particular archaeological interest in
the south east which includes Bronze Age
round barrows
um and a burial probably early medieval
with further burials known to the
southeast and South and also a Neolithic
pit was some interesting place deposits
the archaeological advisor to the OPA
requested that need to be preserved in
situ
and the majority of the center of
Interest was already anticipated as open
space
so we defined a archaeological exclusion
Zone the purpose of that being to
control any or avoid any below ground
impacts in that area
other archaeological remains in the
Central and Northwestern part of the
site there are some some prehistoric
remains there as well can be addressed
by archaeological recording which would
be excavation and or watching brief
which can be secured by way of a
condition
and going back to the discussion earlier
on about the breeding birds area that
area is also going to be an area for
archaeological protection
but that's not going to be an area that
will be some places that came up before
it's not going to be a matter which is
subject to an area which is subject to
excavation is that the intention that
area is just going to be kept as
the architectural remains will just
remain there and there's no
Prospect is there any Prospect
whatsoever of those being excavated
well they've investigated already in the
archaeological trial trench evaluation
which is which is characterized the
deposits and the purpose of the clinical
exclusion zone is specifically to
preserve them in situ yes in perpetuity
so that no it um there's no intention to
investigate them further
it's a general
um best practice is to preserve domains
where you can have interest so
um
we wouldn't be seeking to excavate them
okay
thank you I think that's all clear from
the uh
written submissions
as well so I've got no further questions
from that the actual condition itself if
I've got any particular comments on that
I'll raise those in the conditions
session
um
[Music]
okay so it comes to four
is that at this point and this is in
terms of the justification for the harm
to the designated Heritage assets and
wherever any such harm is outweighed by
public benefits when I was writing this
I was sort of thinking this might be a
matter which might just be left for the
planning witnesses to deal with in the
uh in the later and formal sessions but
the agreed position is between the
council and the propellant that the harm
that would result would be outweighed by
the public benefits this is just the
harm to the designated parishes assets
nothing to do with the overall sort of
planning balance or obviously the
indigenous is in view but as I
understand it that's the agreed position
between the parties
okay
either way
one point I need to go by and obviously
consider that myself but it might will
just be that where that needs to be
picked up it's best picked up by the uh
by the planning Witnesses is that
reasonable
yes I would defer to the playing access
okay
um
foreign
just now where I need to view things
from can be included in the overall site
visit uh schedule and as usual a map is
probably the most helpful in that
regarded map and a sort of list of all
the places will be really useful
something that you know we can refer to
as going around the site so it was
almost going to be added that would be
good thank you
okay
uh thank you Mr that's helpful thank you
as I say I'm not you know I said before
I think sort of most of the evidence
that that regard can be taken from the
written submissions but yeah I thank you
thank you for your additional
clarifications just now any further
comments on heritage
before we
move on
no thank you
okay thank you everybody okay so that
gets us to the end of item
five uh I'm also very close to lunch
so when we return from lunch it will be
we'll move to the sort of the formal
more formal proceedings so to speak and
I think I sort of mention this in my
introductions that this will involve
evidence-in-chief cross-examination and
uh re-examination
and so whereas so far the sessions have
been quite informal and obviously the
opportunity for questions and comments
uh I just like all leadership parties to
be aware that in the more formal
sessions there will be an opportunity
for questioning those witnesses that you
are sort of in disagreement with but
those only have to be at the relevant
point when I asked for them so during
The Advocates
um examination in Chief
cross-examination and re-examination if
everybody else could remain uh
absolutely silent please and that will
be much uh appreciated
uh so after lunch and I propose like
yesterday we'll have an hour for lunch
so we come back at uh two o'clock seems
seems reasonable and it will firstly be
the turn of Mr Hester that I'm presuming
is still
uh able to
uh
pretend so that's good and obviously
yeah what we talked about earlier on in
terms of any appropriate breaks at
appropriate times I will you know ensure
that we will have those and if both
applicants can be mindful of that as I'm
sure you will be as well
um
so we'll after lunch we will start with
uh examination in Chief of Mr Hester
what's who's your remind me Mr Upton of
your time estimates for that
but
I think I was along the lines about 40
minutes
um what I'll try and did obviously take
it relatively slowly so people can
follow
and what people should be aware is
There's a summary proof that I was going
to use as the basis for that and then
perhaps go to one or two of his
appendices just as by reference so
um it won't be necessary to have lots of
jumping around for documents but I can
imagine just because it's online it will
take a little longer so I think it reads
me confident about 40 minutes but you
might ask for some leeway okay yeah okay
yes
and then
resume sorry Mr
I think Mr Morris your microphone might
be on and he's turned it off now okay so
those documents just so everybody's bear
in mind what I said earlier on so the
documents which anybody who wants to
sort of follow it with actually the
documents sort of inference them are on
the screen could you just clarify what
those are again just for people who are
do
for the purpose of Mr Hester's main
evidence yeah there's a a main proof of
evidence with two appendices called A
and B uh which I think have been put on
the website separately
um there's then a summary proof and what
we were going to do is have him to read
from the summary proof which gives
people the overall feel
um and
I think that's going to be the the main
documents you'll need to give that maybe
need to refer to Mr cordray's uh proof
and uh response
um but those are the core documents
excuse me to be well be aware of and may
need to have to hand
um I'll check if there's anything else
over the lunch break but
uh what we've tried to do is to
keep the documentation fairly simple for
the presentation
um because obviously the references are
to those documents within them but I
wouldn't be surprised we have to jump
off into other documents later on but um
so if the presentation that's what we
hope to do
okay thank you
and obviously from my perspective
there's quite a bit of evidence on on
viability and affordable housing
obviously my point of views I need to be
absolutely clear on what the sort of
disagreements between the parties are in
the particular areas and obviously those
sort of the reasoning for those and the
cross-examination of that as well
um
okay uh
Mr Williams your cross-examination just
thinking about timing I think I've got
you down as
I literally not getting down as two
hours
which is that sort of in terms of
thinking about what we're talking about
giving sort of breaks would it be a sort
of a moment to sort of break and do that
in two parts is that possible because
given what
the situation with Mr with Mr Hester or
of course as I said yesterday
um
it's important that Mr Hester gives
evidence in a way that suits him and and
how he's feeling and yeah um
I can divide up the questions into as
many parts as many parts as you like in
order to facilitate that okay but I do
think about two hours overall of
Question Time feels about right still
okay so let's work this through we start
at two o'clock two o'clock till 2 40
will be examination in Chief uh
maybe then just a short sort of uh
recomposure sort of break and then two
hours
uh following that so that's going to
take us to what I'm thinking about is
that that might take us to my sort of 5
p.m point and that would leave
re-examination is that a particular
issue for
would that be particularly Rich
obviously that there could be no sort of
discussion between you Mr Upson and your
your Witnesses of course everybody knows
but from generally I try to not leave
overnight sort of breaks but it might it
might be inevitable in this case
I think you're right I think we just
work around those and the useful thing
is I still have Mr and Mr Livingston to
sort of check things with if needs to be
so it's not that I'm in the situation
where I've only got one person who knows
about planning so I think it will it
should be fine
okay Miss Williams are you happy with
that I agree I think we'll have to see
how we go I mean I as I said two hours
is my best estimate
um it might be that it's
a little bit out one way or the other
okay okay okay
that sounds fine uh let's all break for
lunch it's been quite a long morning
starting at half nine so I'll now
adjourn for lunch and we will return at
two o'clock
thank you sir thank you everybody
foreign
excuse me and time to recommence the
inquiry
um
went up to
item seven on the inquiry program which
has discussed before we're going to
amalgamate with uh item 10 which is the
council's witness Mr Hester on
affordable housing viability and uh
planning matters just before we do are
there any outstanding housekeeping
matters that anybody wishes to raise at
this point
no okay that's good
um in which case
um
it's over to you Mr Upton to introduce
Mr Hester and proceed with his
examination in Chief
I've just seen as a hand raises I was
about to open my mouth if you wanted to
just
there is and yeah it's Miss Mr Hand uh
sorry Mr Hester I have to leave you
waiting for another moment or two while
I
um
Mr Hand your hand is raised
uh yes it is Sir um just for
just before we start this session
um as you uh sorry I'm planning advisor
to the uh rule six party yeah um
yes you'll be aware that all six parties
viability consultant Mr Austin isn't
being asked to provide further evidence
for um this section of the inquiry
um and uh an indication of the
um considerations behind that decision
which was only made late
um later the day on Friday of last week
um anyway there's an indication in um in
the um so swra's opening statements to
that effect
um which is Stickman
um pointed out right at the beginning
statement
um so
um it's therefore regrettable
that the viability yeah segment of
Common Ground was was only agreed and
made available yesterday afternoon
um had it been released earlier then
um the Royal Six party made world of
Arsenal step forced to comment on that
document
and given his views on some of the
assumptions in the FBA Mr Ross is
concerned about cautious nature of the
Dixon server assessment
um and questioned well I didn't pick up
some of the anomalies and inflated
assumptions that he highlighted in his
approach of the FDA so notwithstanding
the comments
on Mr Ross review made by the appellant
experts in the Appellate expert's proof
of evidence
um I'd just like to reiterate on his bit
of resource of the fact that the FBA
assumptions highlighted by him are
regularly agreed by parties in liability
assessment negotiations
thanks
okay thank you and if everyone can take
note
of that and we're going to discussion
about the same for common ground
yesterday in terms of his latest it's
now in uh I'd rather a little bit
earlier in terms of having times
considers Etc but I can assume that the
main parties will take note of what
you've just just said
um and uh thank you for that providing
that submission
well thank you so I think uh we can
obviously proceed on the basis of uh Mr
Hester's evidence and what he is able to
to deal with
um I know I mentioned some documents uh
this week broke right in terms of the
main proof there are a couple of others
uh if it's relevant to those who want to
um Locate them
um obviously I mentioned Mr coolers
proof there is also
um the initial
Financial viability assessment which is
cd110 which has the appendices that only
been referred to but
um just give the reference and the
response that Dixon cell gave to that as
we now know from this morning was the
annex II to the commission reports where
it is banned which is CD 502
okay so
cd110 sorry I'm just getting these up on
my cd110 should be the return or
financial viability assessment it's
about the appendices there's a annoying
is also a version without appendices but
this is the one with
um
okay yeah
there's
the GSP
response to that
we have in CD 5.02
okay just bear with me while I get this
is five cd502
all right you said what we talked about
earlier reporting that within that
rather than the Alex system yeah
and then there are a couple of plans
worth having if you're opening them up
um what is the parameters plan which
though it's labeled version B on the
core documents is actually revision C
when you click through and that's 2.08
and then what we understand to be the
latest version of the development
framework plan revision J which is 2.07
we'll just need the same sort of
position so that is worth having
okay
I have got those
on my screen already thank you thank you
um business I need to introduce Miss
Hester to the inquiry he's
um
to deal with the agreed matters uh and
there should be a proof evidence and
dependencies and a summary and uh all I
was going to do is just
ask Mr Hester to read from the summary
but also in terms of introducing him his
applications and something more details
are set out in the introduction to his
proof where she sets out his experience
both in the logic and private sector uh
and I suppose I was just going to ask Mr
in terms of this site
you station your main proof that you
were instructed specifically in October
of last year
but you were aware of the site
beforehand do you just want to expand
how you got involved and why you're
giving evidence just
hope in terms of
your profession
well I worked as a consultant for a
customer Council working on applications
and appeals probably for about seven
years from about 2005 2006.
and also know the site because of the
many visits and trips that I do for work
and also for pleasure
um and and aware of the football club
around and the site itself so I was I
was instructed in October 2021
um and accepted the
um the instructions to perceived on this
basis
thank you Kevin here I know it's
slightly
I yeah I was going to ask the same
question it's it's not yeah it's
slightly unclear I could hear every word
that was being said
uh
Mr Williams could you hear okay
I could hear but it was certainly a more
muffled tone than is coming through from
yourself and my learning friend
I never says it does have a microphone
addresses where I've just tried to
improve it looks a lot closer than it
was
um is that better
it sort of
marginal improvements all help I think
so we'll have a go okay let's keep it
yeah let's monitor it yeah obviously if
anybody sort of can't hear at any point
or it becomes unclear then uh yeah let
let let me know and let instructor know
so we can intervene as need be yeah so
so with that sort of introductions to
how you got involved if we could then go
to your
summary proof and I said what I was
suggestions we read through
um
actually go through to the vibers and
I'll pick up some points with you just
at the end of that section
but the other two reasons for refusal
and then again I suppose towards the end
when there's the planning balance we'll
pick up some points so can you start I
think in terms of your summary it would
essentially be starting a paragraph 1.3
um after going introduce yourself so do
you want to pick it up there I know some
of it obviously is obvious but it helps
to obviously set the scene yes um
common ground in essence the third
proposal that was an outside with the
exception of the means of access to the
site for which detail approval is being
sent
obviously your proof doesn't go into
those issues but
um I think even it's sort of rather
implicit in when we can't talk about the
planning balance but just to confirm
that
points and taking them into account in
the overall assessment
yes and there's a slight difference in
how to assess impact on Heritage as
there is in terms of impact on sort of
benefits
but how they teach
um the requirements is R2 consider the
public benefits whereas the
better working hard 11 days regarding
the sort of just general benefits but we
tend to decision makers tend to bring
those two together and tell and in my
view
um
the benefits of your proposal outweigh
the harm of things without earlier today
on a medical card if you like on the
Heritage assets
and they're trying to go to your 1.5
so as soon as the LPA determine the
planning application are relevant to
this appeal and the examination Journey
inquiry is the app and suggestion of two
liability assessments
um or general in the cell and support
for the application the first facility
support to the provision of ten percent
housing and the second in support for 15
on the site both
against the residual antiphonium
evidence is prepared to address the
three reasons for a funeral has set out
in the council's decision notices
with it
keep reading 3.1 yeah sorry I guess I
didn't want to interrupt you please do
then do 2.1 through to 2.12 and then uh
I probably separate point to just pause
and pick up some points
there's site allocations provide the
opportunity to deliver development at
scale that will serve both to facilitate
the step change
required and our particular importance
of delivering the plans housing
objectives the appeal site is one of
these strategic housing allocations
the LPA strategic priorities and
objectives for housing the following
follow through into policies that seem
to be informed Housing Development to
help meet effectively assess local
housing needs this includes the delivery
or most sufficient supply of market and
affordable housing of a number size type
and tenure has set out in the policies
up to 450 homes and an oversupply of
public open space On Demand by some 1.9
hectares it appears to be unfails to
meet the requirements of for this
strategic housing education
it will ensure that the development on
the site will underperform only to
relief for having this market and
affordable planned on the site it will
result in the local plan underachieving
on maintenance housing Supply
requirements across the district and the
appeal submission fails to demonstrate
that by not proposing 550 homes on the
site that it has met in the comments for
making an efficient Knoxville use of the
land
instead of the required 30 of affordable
housing across the site the equator
proposal is for 15 across the site it
follows therefore about the appeal
proposal under provides on the supply of
affordable housing plan for the site
at the assessment of the appeal proposal
does not use the dwelling types and
sizes required by the local phone
policies and their supporting strategies
and assessments it does not use housing
products and mixes within the ranges set
out in the specific housing market
assessment 2016 and it has updated and
reviewed by the local housing units
assessment to 2021.
furthermore it does not reduce the
minimum floor space sizes required by
the nationally described space standards
and as required by policy commuted by
the form of an open plan
third effect not only does the appeal
proposal not provide 30 affordable
housing on the site but the scheme is
not policy compliant in other respects
the fva submissions have only assumed to
demonstrate that the appeal proposal is
not viable enough to provide 30
affordable housing on the land the FBA
submissions have not considered other
assumptions to see where the different
schemes or different approaches might
generate better availability outcomes to
increase the federal housing provision
on the site
the FDA submissions do not test or other
assumptions on burning mix sizes two
years and times
the Baseline fva sought to be on a
scheme that reflects the expectations in
the local plan
that's why I say that again the Baseline
FDA ought to be on a scheme that
reflects the expectations in the local
plan
without this it is difficult to come to
a full understanding as to what extent
the scheme will be unviable against the
requirements of the local plan
if it was failing to do this cast out on
the adequacy of the refuas to justify
the scheme not making the policy
requirements of a local plan
we're considered at the better place for
assessing the viability of development
site is ethic the detailed planning
stages
I anticipate that the sale of the land
with pen admission to the house Builder
will lead to a Refresh on the housing
mixed types and sizes all of which will
affect the value of the site and the
students liability
in Mighty with the failure of the appeal
provision to meet the policy
requirements on number sizes types and
links I consider that it is too early to
conclude that 450 homes on the site will
not be viable enough to provide 30
percent Federal housing
the details of the scale are not fixed
as they appears in the outline but
assumptions had to be used on mixed
sizes and types in the feas
there is no one approach to the delivery
of the site and it is of concern for me
that the scheme is being presented this
way
but there's also of some concern that
the FBA has only tested the appellants
preferred and one and only scheme and
it's not considered other schemes or
other assumptions that are relevant such
as the requirements of the development
plan are numbers type sizes aliex
fixing the sale partnership have
provided high-level examples of how
these changes in the FDA could increase
the viability of the steam as shown in
the appendix of my good Developers
if you're the high and pressing need for
local needs housing to be provided for
through the local plan and importantly
on the Strategic housing site that
anticipates up to 550 homes and a policy
compliance scheme the viability for
evidence does not demonstrate adequately
enough but the requirements for 30 food
houses should be lowered to 15 as
submitted by the repellent
balance
[Music]
thank you and sorry to hear the cough
but I see dioses now
um what I suggested is we went to your
appendix the useful jumping off point to
pick up some of the criticisms that have
been raised about um the approach that
you've suggested should be taken to the
Bible
and
is the summary of what happened to the
local plan station I didn't think we
need to go into that at this stage but
what I was against yesterday we go to
appendix B which is
um where you produce the decent cell
Partnerships uh report dated 13th
December 2021 uh where they go through
some of these um
points and also say we can pick it up as
we just go through as a sort of
framework
um they start out in this report by
obviously mentioning
um their involvement back in 2020
uh and what they were looking at
um and make the point that they didn't
then look at the
uh review in
um Junior 2021
um
in terms of this was their initial
um involvement
um
they then go back of course to the
local
plan of what they call Strategic level
testing
um and that's the page two of this note
um
no
this was a couple of broad points
to be made of says it's not the same
system that's being done now and the
first question is is to what level can
we place weight on what the local plan
assessed in terms of its assumptions I
think one of the points was made about
abnormals and how they were treated I
mean how do you approach what was done
at that stage
well I think in those days uh under the
previous
ly Guidance the
uh he wrote local plans were not
expected to go to the margin on
viability I think that's the word in the
previous year
and therefore
um reasonable buffer was the approach of
the Dixon cell work on the local plan
so the reason we welfare included things
like 10 million pounds towards say
section 106 agreements or contributions
Etc
firm or public subsidy
um 20 affordable housing a 20 profit
um they've used but also they use the
specific policy compliant poorly mix
that matched the smart which had been
published products available in the
production list were so we undertook the
assessment based on the what we would
say policy compliance scheme in terms of
housing they had a generous approach
towards everyone laws and accreditations
um and they put in a reasonable by 42
percent uh
so although it's a high level appraisal
at that stage there were a certain
parameters that may work within which
are
um helped to guide and see the
assessment about the scheme was
considered to be or the eradication of
the site was considered to be sound or
there are primary sectors
the sizes they used and the comparison
in this note
um out of order because of course in
terms of the history they then get
involved to review the site-specific
financial availability work done in June
2020 which is
that report that we were mentioning is
an x to the commission report and it is
CD 5.02
if you want to turn to that it's uh this
was the extent they then review matters
as we know
um said it was a reasonable uh report
reasonable assessment Point that's what
it described
um very particularly further to raise on
that
with regard to
um DSS completely agreed with our
assessment etc etc but um when you look
and dive into the Dixie Cell response
in 2020 and it's not actually the case
and so I encourage you said to look at
the differences between
Hills commentary that this is complete
an agreement with Dixon sellers because
Dixon's cell were only asked to consider
the costs and values that were provided
within the FBA firstly they weren't
invited to conduct their own FDA and
they were asked to look at costs and
buildings
they were asked to look at policy
compliant scheme in terms of housing
makes 10 years acceptable
so
that's one starting point
um
I think in
the applications which informative
so the online sentences
um
their response to the
jlfeas the same appears fair at this
stage
um but in power 4.1.1
I think it's worth noting because this
is what leads me to other points I've
made in my evidence
um we note that the application is an
outline only therefore might be subject
to change at preserved matters which
could affect the probability position as
it stands detailed information related
to the name of the costs or indeed The
Firm skin proposals is not available
the source of the scheme means that the
vulnerability outcome is very sensitive
to relatively small looking changes in
your Essentials
um and then they then set out
why they think it's fair and what they
also query along your points
but I don't think it's right that you
you should accept that
is
jss is the JLS um comments that the
Dixon silver and can complete agreement
with
um
then in all elements they tell you the
Dixon cell
our work was to assess the values of
course which are variables but they
weren't asked to consider policy
compliant approaches that
for example size 10 you mix certain
types Etc which is part of the concerned
thank you
um
again going back to the appendix B and
the more recent work by DSP
um
they stage they then obviously
requested by The District Council to
look further at different scenarios and
it's the page four current review stage
one
um and then they pick up at stage two
they alluded three different
um
scenarios uh one the best appraisals
they call it then one with the 2016
housing market assessment mix
and then one with the 2021 uh mix
um
probably worth just picking up the the
poison this um status of the
31 review of the housing market
assessment Ms Falls made the point that
there is some consultation going on uh
which it is part of
um what status do you apply to it as a
result
the the policies SP 22 and sp23 allow
for updates or reviews or documents that
supersede the smart and that's that's
stated in the wording and this is one of
those documents it's a document and
support of
which identifies what the current local
needs or housing needs are
is described in the summary of the uh of
that document that it is a smart update
and
in effect it provides us with the
current position on housing needs
um there is a document that's also being
prepared to support the local plan
review which is just commenced in the
first consultation as it is in play at
the moment
but I give that I did this document
um significant weight because it's a
document that's it is an evidence-based
piece of work and there is actually no
other evidence-based piece of work
that's as relevant but as up to date as
this one
um and that's how I see the importance
of this particular document
the local plan review process just to be
clear yeah it's not a document in the
same way this law was an adult and that
had to be adopted uh it was a document
that served and provided the evidence
for the policies to be to evolve on the
plan to evolve
thank you
um
in terms of the assumptions that he used
in the review
um
just doing the Dixon cell document the
first thing they pick up is the the way
the costs have changed especially in
between
June and they say November
um there's been increase
in terms of the
costs a building I put it put it simply
as that and there is this dispute that
um
Mr cordray would prefer to use I think
what do you call probably some right bit
Kent value
for increased build costs uh whereas
Dixon seller using a more specific than
it uh
location
um
obviously I've said how the explanations
for it but what's your view as to how
the costs should be approached
just increased so I should say well I
think the difference between us is that
the difference between fix and sell and
and
countries work is that as you say that
we've capable of yes when I say way on
abs
information to rely on in terms of the
local
there is
and I think so that's why I defendant
position
s if you like have been used
um
but also the effect costs were used in
the high-level viability appraisal of
the local plan
the effect
that the guidance suggests that people
do providers suggest
uh with regard to affordability
assessment is submitted to a company a
pay application
is simply based upon anything back to
the viability assessment back inform the
plan and the applicant should provide
evidence of what has changed since then
so I think it's for the
the Appellate on the applicant repellent
to
justify why they now think that the
kentwired approach to costs is a more
specific and applicable to this site
when this site was assessed under the
Planet approach and as one of the
difficulty of paint
is that it's such a it's such a cool
brush I mean this case is extremely
expensive place to live uh and also to
build housing
um and
hopefully although you'll probably get a
better range
in terms of uh you know to assess
impacting costs it
it planned its huge and I think the most
appropriate place to look at
coasts in this case is the local area
providing that we have enough
information to to be able to do that
which I think we do
you gave a reference to PV James at
eight something can you just repeat that
within section just I know it's a
vibrancy section but just for those who
need to find it
that's enough of a reference and we can
probably pick it up but yes the PPG
deals with Iverson one section so
hopefully zero zero eight gets the right
paragraph
um
thank you
um that's the the bill cost issue and
then going back to the
um Dixon cell note
uh the sales value assumption I don't
need to ask you about because that's
essentially Mr cordray's seen the point
and plugged it into his uh
response
um but there is still a point about
dwelling mix and
um which is page eight of Dixon soulmate
and of course
um
yeah
I should just talk about the joining
makes sorry that's which is
um whether not just whether something is
a a flat or a house or three bedrooms or
two bedrooms but also
I suppose the
the type of whether it's detachable
sandwich attached and the rest of it so
um
the description mostly you've made and
picked up that the original
um appraisal used a different
mix
is and then there's a alternative mix
now Mr cordray's proof in his section
five has you now dealt with this point
or is there still an issue
so
there's also a number of questions at
the same time
so
just to for the inspectors to explain
and it might what I've included in
appendix B which I hope it's come
through the proof of evidence is that
I'm not trying to really look at the
Dark Art of
um
liability assessments what I'm trying to
suggest is that
you only have to move a few assumptions
around to get a different outcome
and um but is that the fact that we
the Strategic review of the local plan
and the policies and the approach to
this particular site has undertaken
using a policy compliant housing types
and mixes including
the sales of field space that you met at
the end e double s
um just to call this liability
assessment has not done that and and in
addition has proposed 88 units which
actually under the minimum standard for
two-bedroomed houses
um and therefore
what I asked DS to do just from that
simple exercise was to say well actually
find information didn't normally be
granted for two bedroom houses with over
70 square meters so could you look at
how that affects
by a bit of value and and therefore the
vulnerability
they must record this
um necessity of outside of the units is
below what would be an acceptable
standard for that particular building
um
and it's
it's a question mark as to how much
weight is it attached to
this part of this assessment
um
when you look at
um Mr called this
uh
assessments
okay it's the proposal
The Proposal in terms of the parameter
plans suggest
and
um
two and a half story development well
Mr crawdry hasn't assessed any three
story development tool in his appraisals
and if they had done
the crawl space would have to have
increased
but that's one another concern
um
sorry well I could I can't remember all
of your questions
it was sorry if I asked very broadly
about the difference in the mix and the
type of house but I think no no that's
not it yeah I mean the other important
element is
and yet that is quite an important
requirement of the
tour and the
um needs housing assessment
he said
it's as if
to paraphrase this as if the appellant
has said well this is our Steam and by
the way it's not viable it kind of reads
like that you know we haven't provided
any other assessment other than the
units that we want to be in the school
um and so what I try to do is through my
preference is
this challenge uh the assumptions that
have been used to appraisal
because I don't at the end of the day
and we'll probably get on to this I
don't think it's a significant weight
should be given to the financial
liability Pleasures in order to testify
overcoming the federal housing policy
deployment
thank you
okay
um
say I maybe a couple of points to arise
on that but the
just looking at what the appraisals that
Dixon cell then do in terms of the
results if you change these points
they have a section at page 11 saying
latest trial iteration appraisal results
um and can I just pick up this was the
first point that they make there that
paragraph
that talks about the applicant's June
2021 appraisal
which was for 15 affordable housing
indicated that the residual land value
was three million therefore there was a
shortfall against the egregious bent
March land value of 1.7 million
and taking down this deficit the outcome
represents an adjusted return position
and then it's it's just it's 15.2
percent within the 15 to 20 range and
um I suppose just wanted to make this
point asked if you'll be when we're
looking at this profit point
and the PPG talks about a range of 15 to
um I suppose in your experience how
should that be approached
well I I think I think it would be
helpful to
um
and I I don't see any issue with at
least selling what they're 15 to 20
range would be
but clearly clearly with the deficit
that's identified by DS of 1.7 million
or the difference between
Benchmark land value and the residual
land value we're doing 1.7 but still
then retaining
profit within that 15 to 20 range I
think that's I think it's something else
it's another assumption or another uh
alternative that could be looked at
because at the end of the day what the
local Authority is looking for is the
maximum amount of affordable housing
that can achieve with policy compliance
with the different homes of size type
and mix that they're seeking to deliver
based upon assessed need
um that's because you know big
assessments that have been going around
but we don't have that we have this is
our scheme
that's exactly what it is
now
decent cell then have some results of
their appraisal testing using
the this set of assumptions uh for the
three different versions v101 102 103
and they've got two tables one for the
70 and a half percent profit assumption
and one for the 15 uh assumption
um this is I think where the correction
note comes in doesn't it that uh as Mr
Cody pointed out that the there was a
weakness within the Argus
um software that you can have stamp Duty
uh learn to submitted um
even though it should be included and
that's what the creation note picks up
um
refresh in the button when you do the
Argos model
because I understand it but in terms of
the difference that makes
um it's in some assessments
it's 100 000.
10 and the second assessment is around
200 000 pounds so in
in terms of the overall approach to
biability on the skin the size that's
not actually not a very significant
difference it's a different change
to carry out a number of these
higher level assumptions trying to use
as much information from AAL Society
assessments as possible just to really
look at how
if we move costs and values around
um but keep to policy compliance so you
do end up with different outcomes I mean
the fact that
this is an outline scheme
where the proposals haven't really been
worked up in any detail there will be a
difference and from experience
um that's exactly what happens because
house builders themselves
uh obviously you can save on cost clear
efficiencies
and usually have a better understanding
of the values that are likely to
generate with this type of product and
the force-based sizes that they're
likely to
obtain I suppose just as an example I
should have said this earlier
the last
two big housing schemes that I acted for
the landowner on
um the inspectors benefit it's about
town along to the West which is in
Herman Bay
um
first thing for 800 units plus 11
strategic Road and the second scheme was
granted at the end of last year 450.
experience with a row through the site
the
house Builder on
the house Builder on the first skill for
800 this Countryside and the RSL is
places for people
and their two bedroom units range
between 71 and 80 square meters
including affordable
and on the 450 scheme
uh
the Fairway are the house builders and
are they RSL
and they are coming out at 75 square
meters for their two bedroom properties
and just to throw another one in because
I
um funny Netflix and sell well it dates
me for staying down in Sussex and
the RSL or the school in that case it
wasn't a big scheme but they wanted the
two-bedroom houses to be 79 square
meters so in other words all of the
units affordable end or market for two
bed for school above the 70.
as they can
it doesn't that doesn't mean that the
bigger the floor space the more viable
houses are because there is a cap to
that you can't just increase the size of
a two-bedroom
indefinitely because it would then
become
so there is a there is a kind of range
at a house built of views
um but it won't be under 70 square
meters it will be 70 plus and it's 70 on
above
can and let's just figure out the
question I think says it might all these
figures by one or two houses because
they've tried to
equate the increase in profits a number
of additional affordable housing units
that could be
um put forward and I think so it's on
the
2016 mix under the smart
um it would I think something in the
order of what they say
um 24 or additional eight units could be
I suppose than 22 or 16. and if you
reduce the profit
I think they say 39 or 33 units could
then become 37 or 31 I presume is that
roughly how it works the I know it's
always a rule of thumb about what level
of subsidy of all housing might require
to have additional units
yeah I mean because we've not had any
piece of work that actually serves us
about the based position or the platform
is we haven't had a policy from client
praise or a full appraisal policy
compliance it's not been submitted and
neither it's been submitted through
or with the opportunity
um
I think
so there is a variation
um and it I think it's important that we
understand at least the starting
position before we can look at well do
we therefore need to
assessment but um we would then be
looking at more why can't you increase
the size of your of the unit numbers on
your site
because
um
employmentation more units equals a
better viability or more units equals a
better value
on the basis that
house yourself for more than your body
that you build them for
so I think we would get to that stage
then as well and to see what the
differences are and see what my
additional units may be required in
order to achieve for 30. but we haven't
got to that stage yet and
I've been inspector in this effect just
to determine what's important
yeah okay
pick up then a couple other points have
been raised which is
um supporters make a point that in his
view the
the scheme that was assessed reflected
an optimized form of development on the
site I would consider this is your Vice
verses
um it's the ways about what you attach
to but is is it an optimized form
or who knows
um we've not seen anything
um what I would say to apply that to the
inspector is that even the
um
but made a few comments
but I think I think we want the evidence
and I still feel that what we've got is
this is our scheme
we like it
um
so there isn't any evidence of
how esteem has evolved I mean it's an
illustrative master plan
but in parameter plans or the parameter
plan is to be considered at this stage
but there's no evidence and there is no
ability for any assessment so actually
um you could do this that or the other
on the site to provide on alternative
scheme which would be have more units on
it and so for an example
if you don't want to use in an example
hopefully when I look at the
um perimeter plan I'm going to refer to
this now
um to revision C
and if you keep a finger in
supervision
which includes the master plan document
or the master plan in it this is Page 38
yeah 4.3
when you look at the
parameter plan I'm just going ahead and
hoping that everybody's got it in front
of you is that
is that okay
um
so when I look at the parameter plan
you've got areas there for two-story
two and a half story
but so hopefully on your site this you
would have seen
a significant all in topography from
shutting down Road into the valley and
and obviously the landing goes up on the
other side and that's a 10 meter drop
will hunt
when you stand on
the highway of Shopkins
pushes and agitation I think the plans
show that that's a 1.3 later
so
the more lines
looking at the topography and the cold
sores having been on the site there is
scope or
having a look at a very look at the
heights I mean that's the cool thing as
I said as an even assessment stories
um
but if you look at the different shading
of yellow and it's not it's appeared to
be as as on cope with it I think it's
online
um but there is step to increase Heights
because you will not see
significantly the difference in Heights
will make because they are set back in
the road and they're further into the
valley so I think there is still to
increase height
here are those to to increase the areas
of dark yellow
I accept
then it should really do to the north of
the site because the south of the site
Rises up and then therefore you have
more of an imposing but most of the
development on the south of the site is
two-story are proposed to be
two stories so there is an ability to
increase in height there's a good
ability to thicken up because the skin
doesn't propose any lump head fats
so there's that approach is well aware
if we if we included one bed flat
into the scheme is probably an
opportunity to thicken up in terms of
the number of units in you know
comparatively limited area like coverage
of the site
but also and I know that this is only an
illustrator but I think because
the reason I've raised this is because
we're underachieving on affordable
housing and what I'd suggesting to you
sir is that
they sit there for another look at
how people increase the level of fully
housing through this development so when
I look at the master plan and prepare it
with
the parameter plan
there are a number of red buildings that
are focal key buildings
in the development
um
wasn't prepared by an architect
but
um
nearly half or most of these red
buildings are two stories
and when I was prepared schemes I've
been involved with
um Place making and
schemes for almost recently the 450 and
the 800. you really need to focal
buildings to make an available design
tail speed statement
it's all ready
there's already uh
an indication at these buildings would
only be two stores which limits
conjunction points
they provide us a visual design
statement as part of the school
but they just seem to be randomly
located and could have been a full story
or even more so or in certain locations
on the Northern side so
we say that
because I think they feel the same
could have looked at
seeking to provide more affordable
housing through increasing the numbers
of Helix on the site and I made the
point
in my approved remedies that actually
the open space requirement include
policy SP 21
is to provide a minimum of 4.4 hectares
of open space
for those provided or the skill provides
for 6.3 hectares
of open space
um and okay that
you may think well that's good because
that's better for master plan and then
Place making but if it means that
there's going to be less development on
the land or less housing on the land and
I think that needs to be looked at as
well because of the free with the
scaling net
4.4 hectares of open space it will allow
another 1.9 hectares of developable land
for housing
so
there are a number of ways of looking at
how to increase affordable housing on
your site
rather than accepting
this is our scheme do you like it by the
way it's not viable
um and we can't meet your requirements
so I think I that the point of I've
tried to make in my
proof of evidence and in a very
long-winded not interesting way now is
that this isn't the only scheme that can
be delivered on this land
and the local authorities being faced
with giving up the Strategic site
um and and what's required on the
Strategic side in terms of housing
numbers and the federal housing to meet
local needs
local housing
we need to look at this a little bit
more detail
um
committee did at the attempts of
considering the application
could I just interrupt and ask a quick
question for my uh clarification when
you mentioned focal buildings on the
parameters plan
what's that I can't see the key for the
focal building
um
if a suit up one page
yes
foreign
[Music]
shared stroke focal space is that's not
the same
I think it's one we had identified but
you say in the design access statement
there is and Page 38 was it just yes
38 I'm
right I'm on page 38 oh okay that
drawing
um one page you'll find the key
right oh I see focal key
focusing disabilities
so
the point is normally I see I identifier
buildings which can
we're going to visual
you know a bit of creativity bit of
innovation something that draws the eye
and the general telescope
um
shoes or gateways or each points into
certain areas of character areas of
science so
the assertive is to be randomly located
and many of them are two stories so
there's not much of scope
okay thank you yeah sorry for
interrupting but I just wanted to
Clarence I think you can understand so
that was a point about optimization the
other question I'll just ask you about
it's been said of course there are
review mechanisms built into the
planning obligations if the figures of
viability were to improve
um obviously that may help in terms of
the numbers but is there a how does that
deal with I suppose the planning
um concerns about affordable housing
um
I I think can I answer that in a number
of ways sir and
um
and I think about
when I
we've seen that I've seen another
I've seen that another reiteration of
the unilateral has come forward into our
form to me uh I don't have an
opportunity to look at it
we came in at thunderstorm I think
um
we don't get to this is this is the
Apparently intellectual Undertaker to
you
um and it's not something that the local
Authority
um
but firstly
um to cover the nppf
[Music]
there are any fulfillable housing is
identified policy should specify the
type of federal housing required as
expected to be met on site unless
that position or an appropriate
Financial competition and you can be
robustly justified
um
sometimes communities
um alongside that in terms of the
planning policy guidance upon on this
um certainly the current people came and
certainly the forerunners to people
seem to approach reviews is an approach
on development of ground field sites and
sites and or sites requiring mitigation
or where there is a level of uncertainty
well I have no rest or costs
um even if it's underground or if you
can contact in the contamination Etc so
it's a review that's mainly used to
cover levels of risk and uncertainty
uh rampant's got an SPD on this point
but it's not something that's been
identified as part of this application
that there is anything
unturned underground because it's a
green field site so from that point of
view
um is not necessary as it is the only
effect the contingencies
so it's not anticipated either
development
but
a local Authority point of view this is
a strategic site where the level of
feudal housing should be located on the
site to form part of the next balance
community
um
the importance of affordable housing on
so it's also connected to the fact that
it's the site is accessible to the town
center and to the other facilities of
public facilities amenities that are
around
the local preparing sectors
of an explanation behind using strategic
sites
um
being an important extensions to urban
areas because it then limits the sort of
finding
communities and and building or
investing best and versatility of
cultural land
and the fact that there was very little
in terms of available sites in the urban
yeah so for the for the council to take
or I don't know where that will be but
it certainly won't be as an accessible
location as we can and sites would be to
be acquired
so
the developers deliver food of housing
as part of larger schools more
efficiently
rather than all smaller sites
um
and
I mean the international version of the
Union election that I've seen
I mean Mr Williams
spoke to the spoke of the plural phrase
the ruler for this
in his opening which I think was quite
funny
um I mean so there was another planning
phrase that I've developed
it's proposing a mix of units that
doesn't hasn't even been tested by Mr
Clinton it has any of the questions
about this
application
but I think
to sum up on that point
this is an outline application
significantly by our house Builder
because of observient is recycler
that the Lord approach that way too look
at this and live in
and the greatest certainty as well in my
view
is to impose the 30 now
and allow the developer
who is going to build out the sort of
house Builder I'm going to build outside
to come back if need be
when they've got more detailed
information on costs product
finally
exception having been to the market
um to come back in the future so I don't
think the review is necessary if a
review is necessary a starting position
should be 30 affordable with the policy
compliance scheme and let's just see how
the house Builder does with that
the other point is that
full experience that the figures and the
numbers do get hidden from open
authorities
they'll have a more finesse
understanding of value
around
and I think the proposal in Mr Porter
has ever been or submissions is that
this would be two outlets so it could be
two developers that would have to be
dealing with
um and so in
at the end of the day I really don't
think a review is
appropriate to a scheme like this I mean
the 450 scheme that got positioned at
the end of last year
Elway homes for example
there is a phasing plan in the section
106. but anyway I'm just going to build
the whole site irrelevant of the phasing
plan they'll just keep building and ask
the energy developer wants to do is to
stop development because it just
expresses way to risk on costs
so
a developer will want to just keep going
and if there's reviews in this
106 where the developers needs to stop
or
as an uncertainty is whether they can go
forward in the next phase of this game
it just makes it
were uncertain for the developer or the
house building and if any benefit is
appropriately done this way which would
be 30 up front
if you have an issue with that okay
let's see your Fitness when you you
deserve the skin and
and worked out the detail of it and that
that would that would seem to be how
it's a cell approached it because
they've said that you know there's three
variations and personal values do have
an impact
um so I suggest to you sir that
over here
appropriate in this case
but if you do think that there is one
starting position should be thirty
percent of the policy compliance scheme
I also find that I I also find it
difficult to see a wave I mean it's
written it's very complicated it's
unilateral in terms of the wording
understand it
has been difficult
at least simply written
and what is it also saying to but
if they're reducing it you're being
forced into a corner for this unit
actually to say
is it 15 percent
is it 30 or any figure between 50 and 30
that you arrive at now I don't I don't
think that's an appropriate way to
uh make a decision and certainly I don't
think it's an appropriate to put that
into you know let's take it that you are
left with coming up with a figure that
you're happy with which hasn't been
actually proposed to you
um you know that's why that's my
professionally
sorry for the old women
I'm conscious you need to to say what
you need to say and and
if those important issue um I think but
in terms of the fibersity point we we
can pause that and go back to your
summary of deals with the other issues
before we come to the planning bars and
hopefully everything fairly uh quicker
are you okay
um to continue it's the the summary you
may have called was our starting off
point we could obviously leave the B
um there's a just a brief section your
summary on the other two reasons for
refusal which we can probably take as
read by now
Earth bit together
um that if the planning obligation is
satisfactory then
community and hybrid infrastructure is
being properly provided
uh and then in terms of the planet case
special protection area there is
mitigation that would be secured
um I don't have anything else to sell on
those deals which leaves the planning
balance but I'm just consciously
obviously we have rather I've shot our
initial hope in terms of timing but are
you still okay to
foreign
your section three of your summary deals
with the planning balance now can I just
deal with this first two no sorry is it
really is one preliminary Point
um your previous been written on the
basis of applying the Tilted balance and
dealing with the policies that are most
materials the decision being out of date
and therefore what's
we've been referring to as paragraph 11
subparagraph D of the mppf
um Point sort of strongly made in
opening by Mr Williams and I supposed to
pick up by Mr ball that an inspector
also needs to consider paragraph 11c
which is everything is in accordance
with a development plan
um
how do you approach that
well
The Proposal is in conflict with the
development plan
um and
so you know
one of your starting points will be
policy recipe 23
oops states that 30 percent shall be
affordable housing so you've got there
is that curvy act at the end of the word
and I won't go to it because I've taken
up so much of your time but
um
and there's then a question of right to
be applied to the financial liability
assessment as to whether that
demonstrates that the level of things or
could be lowered
you the fact that the financial
vulnerability appraisal is not
or has not been carried out on a policy
compliant basis that takes you to SP 22
as the steam has been assessed
the requirements of SP 22 and neither
does it because of the reduction in
affordable housing neither does it meet
the requirements of SP 21
um also I don't think we'd ever see a
prize here because those policies
um or other the appeal proposal is in
conflict with those policies and the
Strategic priority three is set out in
the
in the reason for the future
yeah
um yeah
um and perhaps just before we go to what
you do then say is the correct way to
approach the balance in your summary
there's this point been raised about the
nearby site of somerston Grange
um and the I think the reference is CD
6.04 is the committee report where
um it's been recorded that there's a
resolution to granted there's a decision
notice yet
um where the 250 dwelling
um
permission
um has been given approval with uh I
think it's 18 in terms of the affordable
housing
um to what extent is is that a I think
also Mr Paul just so you've got the
references 5.7.16 but
in terms of that permission to what
extent is that an equivalent uh or
comparable
position
[Music]
um
the application is obviously a 2016
application
um
should be determined shortly I would
have thought that it's a five-year
process
they've been free planning committee
reports on that site or looking at the
steam
the initial scheme came in as a fairly
compliant with the
um like a small another small or set out
in the local plan
and
subsequent to the resolution to plants
um
the percentage of handle housing was was
cleared by the applicant of the
remainder of the stream in terms of
small mix
sizes Etc remain the same it was a large
element of policy blind
but as everyone is
supports what I've just said in working
up the scheme it was identified that
being alone is going to cost four
million pounds more than they have
identified and therefore there was this
round of
um
coming back to the local Authority
um in order to justify drop in the
affordable housing they also offered
in the local Authority would like all of
the affordable to be social care
ownership
um
yeah but there's a site for 250 or for
an 18 fieldable we are assigned at 450
and could increase in my view and the
schemes only offering 15 affordable
um
we are strategic site that was a
slightly planning permission of
certainly with with
um resolution to Grant and ignition
prior to the local plan
adoption
um and therefore
each case is determined on its own
merits and I think there are clearly
differences in case and differences in
the two schemes
and everyone shouldn't necessarily
follow the other in terms of what's been
accepted
thank you um and then I think if we just
turn to what you then say is the the
playing balance
um
we have your pack of 3.1 and I'm aware
not everybody would have heard how you
approach it do you want to read from
your 3.1 please
uh the APA can only demonstrate that
they can deliver between 4.23
4.3 years of doing local housing sites
this is an appear where what has become
known as The Tilted balance of the
paragraph 11d of the mpf should be
applied
given the absence of a five-year Supply
development deliverable housing sites
and the current inability to meet the
housing delivery tests
and right here there is a values to be
applied between the benefits of the
development events the harm of an
expectable in everyday
you know since this is also equal
we recognize that their proposure brings
a number of benefits although at this
stage only an outline the proposal
sheets to deliver up to 450 homes on
which 68 of these would be affordable
this will go somewhere to meeting local
housing rules in the district
proposal would also help to deliver a
key piece of Highway infrastructure to
help me to ride a highway me and to
reduce the pressure on network capacity
in particular traffic Junction coughing
house corner
bear with me to the Social and Highway
in additional homes will have a positive
impact on your local economy not only
will the economic benefit come through
the proportion of the construction and
other related job opportunities for
local people but we also increase
patronage to nearby shop services
and Facilities uh environmental benefits
would include the creation of new public
open space on the site and recover the
benefits in the way
character are overcoming the plan and
balance balance in my view by the
Imperial proposal however
the benefits identified above could have
put equally but the provided by an
alternative scheme in particular the key
piece of Highways infrastructure
required could be provided by another
school whilst retaining the provision of
the means of access to and from the site
in addition to school for 550 homes
would also further and further in
meeting the economic objectives behind
such an annotation and I just want to
make the point
yeah there's no doubt that the appeal
proposal does assist and provide a key
pieces of infrastructure in relation to
the highway it provides the free Road
between second-hand Road and Hearthstone
road and it also makes a contribution
um a significance of his financial
information towards achieving the unit
Circuit Road
but we'd like to
um
say that an alternative scheme could
equally been that
and also because the numbers have
changed from 550 to 450
the
Financial contribution towards the
strategic mode is paid on a
proportionate basis so there's 450 times
roughly five thousand pounds per
dwelling so obviously
seated Road
with the allocated site at 550 is
anticipated
probably going to be a greater amount of
money in the pot so there's a reduction
in the pot
by 500 000 pounds so
although it's a benefit
and clearly around the provision of a
road is important and meets targets the
amount of money that's being paid into
the Strategic port for improving the
general Network
there's a reduction of 500 000 pounds
from what was anticipated through the
allocation of this site for 550 so I
think we'll have to bear that
and hopefully
it won't then encourage other
significantly sized specific sites from
adding housing numbers which are
slightly below what's been anticipated
because that part will increasingly uh
have a greater deficit than those first
anticipated
so in 3.7 the view of the above I do not
consider that the failure to provide 30
people housing has been appropriately
justified by the finance liability
assessment or that their personal school
is the one and only scheme that can be
accommodated on the site
significantly
and demonstrably outweigh the benefits
of doing so terrific
thank you Mr and I know between the
links here presentation well my hope but
hopefully valuable um points so as you
say
um thank you thank you Miss Hester to
the main Institute
about five minutes ago that
you consider it's also contrary to
policies SP 22 and SP 21
so are you saying that in effect in your
view the proposal is contrary strategic
policy 3 and SB 22 and sb21 which is
different to what's on the decision
notice
thank you for asking that question
because SP is fitting the priority
policy
it's the overarching policy and the
affordable housing policy and some
special housing strategy comes from that
priority
um
so the policies in the local plans sit
within that priority and policy
framework so in my view we read them in
context and together not in isolation
um and I think that's important because
I think
the
degrees of refusal sets out the issue
which is affordable housing balanced
communities don't balance the next
communities in sustainable development
you'll find that then
you know it's just sp23 sp22 and sp21 so
the point being is because
SP 23 is in breach
and there is a judgment to be had as to
whether the
Financial liability
demonstrates that the affordable housing
can be lowered I think that takes us to
sp22 and sp21
because the financial vulnerability
assessment
isn't adequate enough
um and should have
included the policy compliance elements
of sp22 and sp21
so that's that's why I've set that out
to you like that so yes I brought some
priority policy but then that thread
goes through the local plan into
policies 23 22-21
okay
thank you
um I just want more my my last question
of clarification that you obviously
mentioned that there's been the
viability appraisal has been done on the
basis of what you considered to being on
policy compliance scheme but just
massive clarification it's not the
council's argument that their proposal
as a whole the whole application is
contrary to the policy requiring a uh
a compliant mix of dwellings is just in
relation to the point about the
viability assessment
yes because it comes back to that matter
of matter of judgment and weight
um if if the scheme had or proposed 30
affordable housing then it's clearly the
council it did not feel the need to go
to SP 22 and 21.
um but because it doesn't and it also
doesn't properly look at what this
policy complied in terms of
the number the types of the floor spaces
the sizes Etc
it's an underachieving
um Financial liability it's not good
enough in order to address the concern
about not having enough affordable
housing
so I think if there's significant levels
at 30 percent
um sp22 could be picked up at detailed
meta stage
okay
thank you uh
you probably need a break now uh so if
we
it's 325 so we're a little bit beyond
behind schedule but if we how long do
you I want to make sure you're sort of
properly arrested
I've taken some currency tonight so I
better not take any more so I'll be back
in five minutes
well I'm happy to give 10 minutes
because I think I wouldn't mind it's a
stretch about his legs for more than
five minutes anyway so because this is
this is going to be effectively this is
going to be the mid-afternoon break so
if we break for 10 minutes if that's
fine for everybody we'll come back at
three uh 35.
okay I'm adjourn briefly for that break
thank you
foreign
okay welcome back
everybody time to
resume
so I feel like I take a position of my
microphone is that better or worse
[Music]
so I keep talking
it's really odd because it's coming
through a different speaker on my system
which I didn't expect
um
say something again to me
I'm here yeah I can I can hear you it
does sound clear actually the only thing
is it's coming through a different for
some reason it's coming through a
different
uh speaker on my uh
no no because I think you've probably
done you've probably got the best I
don't think it's your fault I think it's
my system
um
that's really odd I'm gonna just go back
out to this meeting and come back in
actually that will make any difference
but I can hear it fine it's just
weird for me because it's coming from a
different location but I can't I can't
hear you so there's anything else
what I don't want to do is this which is
like a Murray Walker in person where you
have it right up there so
we'll put it in front of my screen and
uh hopefully that's you know okay yeah
not seems absolutely fine let me just
make some adjustments to my
system to see if I can get my
Snapchat
right yeah that should be okay I can
hear I could hear fine uh so it's now
for uh Mr Williams to cross-examine Mr
Hester and before you start Mr Williams
obviously I want to sort of finish it
round about sort of 5 00 p.m so can you
have that in mind in terms of obviously
all to see how things go but in terms of
when a convenient break might be in
proceedings as you as you go yes
okay over to you over to you
thank you shall I start by identifying
some documents
um that we'll have a look at the first
one which you probably have open is CD
5.2 amongst the gladman core documents
which is the office's report
the version with the attachments yeah
[Music]
um there's also within the councils
called document CD 5.1 which is the
local plan
policies from 2020
that's CD 5.1 did I have that
from the evidence in Chief uh you were
certainly looking at it earlier in the
biodiversity
um session
yeah
it's the council called document 5.1
okay let me just get that
up
um
thank you
foreign
yeah okay thank you
um gladman CD
6.07 which is the PPG on viability
okay yep also Mr Hester's truth and
appendices and correction note which you
will have yeah and also Mr cooldry's
group dependencies and rebuttal please
[Music]
okay proof and rebuttal
um
they've missed the crude proof and
rebuttal
there was no rebuttal from Mr Hester
yeah I've got the Mr I'm just getting Mr
I've got the hard copies of those uh
okay
yeah okay I have those
obviously
um the council's statement of case
please
yeah
CD 1.10 which you did have open sir it's
the original
JL viability appraisal
yeah I've got that
um the viability statement of Common
Ground please
[Music]
yeah okay
um
is that a core document as yet I can
guess a copy from the email if not but
I don't think it's labeled as a core
document nature okay let me just get up
the
foreign
yesterday lunchtime about wasn't it
it's it's it's on the website so it's
where it hasn't got its own separate
call document number but hopefully on
the website you'll find it in about the
first five documents or six documents
there
okay I found it via email uh
as you know no planning inspector likes
to go looking on websites and things so
I'll keep to that
not real right I've got it and there's
load of things on the floor as well so
bear with me
right okay anything else
um there is gladman CD 6.04
which is the sound Western Grange report
and finally
um
the council's CD 5.4 which is the most
recent 2021 local housing need paper
foreign
yes these
right the 2000 yeah the 2021 yeah I've
got that okay
and that's it there I mean I might get
diverted onto one or two others but
they're
I think ones it's helpful to have access
to before thank you and that's enough
Windows to be open from my point of view
I think as well so I haven't done all
that it's next nearly five o'clock
absolutely okay you can continue thank
you okay thank you Mr Hester again to
start with some questions about decision
making
approach please
um first of all
we can agree that under Section 38 6
priority is given to the development
plan
yes considerations
yes I'm struggling to hear that
the very first
other material considerations after yep
and it's well established that an
assessment should be made against the
development plan policies read as a
whole yes
it's also well established that it's the
policies of the development plan that
provide the basis for that assessment
isn't it
yes but you do have to read that in the
context of the plan itself the whole
plan
you read it in the context of the plan
but the purpose of supporting text is
not to add any additional policy tests
to those that are found in the policies
themselves that's right isn't it yes
but you've got to understand where the
policies are coming from in terms of the
objectives behind them
and as do other material considerations
we can agree the framework is plainly a
significant material consideration
yes
and that there's no dispute here that
the two triggers in footnote 8 of the
framework are pulled to engage the
Tilted balance
thank you
it says it works
I mean because in this case there isn't
a five-year housing land Supply
of five years and so that's one trigger
that pulls that that triggers the Tilted
balance and also because the HDT
performance in this District are 54
Falls below the 75 required by footnote
8 within paragraph 11d of the framework
yes
good
and so it's agreed here that the appeal
should be determined through application
of the Tilted balance yes
and that in part because although
Heritage and ecological considerations
are raised neither of those provides a
clear reason for refusing the permission
yes if they expect to feels that
um
seven has been addressed uh then yes the
fertility balance still applies and it's
the council's position that it does
there's Heritage considerations and
ecological considerations have been
addressed yes
thank you can we take up your proof then
please
paragraph 2.15
.
[Music]
do you have that
thank you
she's in your the first sentence there
you say that policies
for the supply of housing are out of
date
yes
the actual
effect of a lack of a five-year housing
land Supply under the framework since
2018.
is that the
policies most important for determining
the application are deemed out of date
aren't they
yes they're most relevant yeah now most
important the policies your wording
reflects the 2012 framework
the actual wording of the 2018-2019 and
2021 framework
deems the most important policies for
determining the application out of date
doesn't it yes that's right
and so
in the context of this appeal
it follows the SP 21 22 and 23 are
deemed out of date
no that's not right
those policies are in accordance with
the substance of the framework
how today isn't about time it's about
whether Lively it's whether it's they
apply to or rather how consistent are
they with no ppf so no I don't accept
that did you want to look at paragraph
11 D please to say that you've got it in
front of you when you answer
the point
[Music]
foreign
policies well that isn't the case
or the policies which are most important
for determining the application are out
of date
and so my my arriving the policies of SP
21 22 and 23
firmly uh in accordance with the mppf
and so therefore they are not down to
date
would you mind just looking at the
footnote Mr Hester
this includes for applications involving
the provision of housing situations
where the local planning Authority can't
demonstrate a five-year housing land
Supply
yes but you have to look at you have to
look at what the policies are aiming to
do
and the council's supply of housing
policies in fact they don't have one
that is the tradition that the council
is relying on
which is out to date but in effect
the policies of 21 22-23
well firmly
but I'm sorry Mr Hester I'm not sure why
you're applying a test of whether
they're in accordance with the nppf when
I'm asking you about footnote 8 and my
question was that
footnote 8 because there's no five-year
housing land Supply because you failed
against the 75 HDT requirement
those policies most important for
determining the application are deemed
out of date
that's the well-established operation of
our footnote eight isn't it yeah because
you have a most local authorities
there's a particular one doesn't have
policies to do with the supply of
housing
but they're only able to think if
they're not uncomfortable if they're in
conflict with the mppa and as I said 21
22 and 23
the substance are in accordance with
young people that's my final position
I'm not sure why you're going back to
policies relevant for the supply of
housing we've already agreed yeah we're
going to the most important for the
determination of the application yes and
do you I would say to the inspector that
the policies that are most important for
the determination of the pool are looked
out to date so take it in stages do you
put forward SP 21 22 and 23 as within
those policies most important for
determining this appeal yes and you
agree that there is no five-year housing
land Supply
can I answer that question in this
particularly
um
firstly that the
with regard to that point
he
thought food and housing Supply is down
to the fact that the housing coming
forward at the moment is not fully made
trajectory there's no policies as such
I was actually accepted as a sound Hazel
strategy by the local planning
inspectors
who anticipated that because 75 of the
housing Supply would come forward from a
strategic housing sites
that there would be a a slow increase if
you don't want to step change halfway
through the plan
so in fact
the thoughtful of housing at this stage
is an unexpected it was expected
but because the local plan is
anticipating a step change and a
significant increase in housing coming
forward when the Strategic sites are in
play
that was accepted as a sound approach by
the inspectors and so therefore so I
would ask you to consider that element
to your weighing up as to the
um
how how much the the policies are on
date with them
okay some back to my question please Mr
Hester
was you agree that there's no five-year
housing land Supply
is a 6.9 of 4.9 with five percent offer
and between 6.2
there is a housing High there Supply
there and that is going that is
anticipated to increase
so there is a there is a question of
wait at least to be applied as to yes
there is a technical breach in terms of
11d and therefore
the intuitive balance is triggered but
so what I'm saying is that who forces
most important for determining the
appeal are in equivalence with the
framework
sorry Mr Hester you're gonna have to
focus on the question can you look at
the main statement of Common Ground
please
paragraph 2.29 sentence one
do you are you disagreeing with what's
in the statement of common ground
you know that's correct if you come back
to my question of a few minutes ago we
can agree that the character is unable
to demonstrate to fight the air housing
land Supply
and the consequence of that see footnote
8 is that the most important policies
for determining the application are
deemed out of date do you agree with
that
so I don't agree with that because the
most important policies for the
determination reputation are in
accordance with the framework so
therefore the water sounds effect I've
answered that question
and where does footnote 8 say anything
about other than where the policies are
in accordance with the framework
demonstrates by their supplies the
trigger
but it doesn't mean to say that the uh
you will ignore
the most important policies uh for the
defender of the application which are
not out of date
so the trigger is applied
but then so in my opinion the
policies on those things significantly
described housing and the affordable
housing policies are in complete
accordance with the objectives of the
nppm so they're not able to take
okay well I'll leave that before
submission to make the game
you know help the aspect by going
through that again
um the turning to the development plan
itself then please and the policies
that CD 5.1
and
the questions I'm asking here
relate
only to reason for refusal one
is that understood I'm not asking you
about reasons two and three
um but just the questions of affordable
housing at this stage is that
understood
and if
we turn to the first reason for refusal
which is also set out conveniently in
that main statement of common ground
foreign
2.1
the first reason for refusal
doesn't identify any policy within the
development plan which is breached does
it
so what I'd like to say with this is
that it refers to a strategic priority
field which is the uh
in particular the reference to to
housing
um so but
what I don't want you to think is that
this is the only this is the end of the
position on the front of the housing
because the development plan needs to be
read as a whole and the
reasons for refusal are related to
affordable housing uh the fact that
they're racing enough and
um
and the creation of balance and
experience in it from that strategic
priority the policies and the eclipse of
the local Authority you've worked its
way into
policies
so
in answer to the question uh is clear
the
there is a refusal references for
student priority three
but
my suggestion and my Approach is that
that doesn't mean that the law or other
policies relevant in the development
plan
to which they directly relate and there
is a threat from those strategic
priorities set out at the beginning of
the development plan
okay just come back to the question
again please the question was the first
reason for refusal does not identify
breach of any adopted adopted
development plan policy does it
so as I said in my previous uh response
what I would like you to consider is
that the uh it does not identify any
particular policy but it does identify
the Strategic priorities of the local
Authority
and in life
with respect to looking at what are the
implications of strategic policy
priority number three in relation to
affordable housing but it does not
identify a breach of SP 21
sp22 or sp23 does it so as I said in my
in my last previous two responses the
priority the Strategic priority relates
to affordable housing and balance and
mixed communities
the policies are then played out or if
you like the threat of that objective
in context has played out into the
policies of the local plan and that's
how it's written and in my view we do
not separate these things out you have
to read you have to read the context
of the development plan together and the
policies and objectives and strategies
and the priorities together
it would be helpful to me
no or yes it asks you a question and
then went on to qualify it in any way
that you wish that's how I've framed the
questions well essentially but the best
for any real questions and I'll give you
my best answers and I'm not going to
answer yes or no to your questions if I
feel that that's not necessary or I
don't want to mislead the inspector or
the inquiry as to what my position is
will say do you want to answer the
question I asked which is the reason for
refusal doesn't identify a breach of SP
21 sp22 sp23 does it
well I did I answer that question but I
personally didn't hear me but I did
answer it by saying in my previous
answer that the policies aren't
referencing the reason for refusal but
I'm inviting the inspector to consider
the importance of strategic priority
three and how that strategic priority
Works its way through the document to
the policies
um
so
so that's how I would like you to look
at me at the issue of the policy and the
priority that set helps whether the
priority
the priority which is set out in all the
music
and it's a requirement isn't it of
article 35 of the procedural order
that
a reason for refusal States the full
reasons for the refusal specifying all
the relevant policies in the development
plan
well I don't know the answer to that but
what I would say is that it's quite
obvious
foreign
level of affordable housing
the fact that it was not identical it
would not meet the identified me for
clinical housing and would not create or
help to create a finance the next
Community I mean and and I think there's
a system the only reason this is
paraphrased and sustainable development
so therefore there are three elements
that need to be considered into one
under that strategic priority so I don't
think
that's as an inspector you're in any
doubt as to what it needs to be
considered
um in terms of the council's development
plan position
at page one of the generals Dayton
Department ground
you'll see at the bottom of the first
reason for refusal
which refers
which refers to the Strategic priority
three if you look at reasons for refusal
Spa sorry two and three
those policies do there
for or there specify each policy of the
adoptive development plan which is
considered relevant to the reason for
refusal don't they that's correct yes
see there's no reason to take an
inconsistent approach just between
reason one and reasons two and three
I think you need just to look to see
what the actual reasons for refuse at
all and what's referenced in them um
because for example that that reason for
refusal doesn't reference the mppf
so
um I I don't think there's any doubt as
to what's the issue in terms of
paralysis environment I don't think
there's any doubt as to what the issues
are in relationships or two if you then
take up the council statement of case
please
[Music]
this document in relation to reason for
refusal one does not identify any breach
of policies SP 21 sp22 or sp23 does it
tonight
the statement of case does not identify
or assert any breach of policy SP 21
sp22 or sp23 does it
thank you
so the Inception under cabinet policy
play again
sets out to you the Strategic priorities
of objectives in the plan
and the positioning requirement or
delivery of sustainable development and
they both set out
actress po2
the housing strategy
which is 259
etc etc
31 37
and then references
so at that stage
um
the Strategic priority address over
planning policy
uh which encourage the position on
um
this week 21
is between two is between three
Etc
it refers to their policies but it does
not identify any breach
of any of those policies does it Mr
Hester
it's a statement of case it didn't go to
that extent the group of evidence
does that
I will come to your proof of evidence at
the moment at present I'm just looking
at the documentation in the council's
name because the reason for refusal
which is required by law to State all
relevant policies doesn't identify any
breach of the development plan and
neither does the council statement of
case we can agree that as a matter of
fact can't we
music
and
the requirement and the need to meet at
local housing needs Works its way
through the development plan into the
policies because that sort of thing
the person was seeking to implement
um
the council's full case that will be
supported by evidence isn't it
and development plan compliance weird
read at the outset is the first step
before we get to proofs
because what the council will be
considering and setting out the policies
in that
and in terms of the council setting out
the policies and policy compliance
in your evidence your proof of evidence
where do you undertake an assessment
against the policies of the development
plan in your proof please
under the main issues for consideration
and then I
decision
my second position
and so I
have other strategic housing allocation
objectives
strategic four to three we're going to
go into SP 21
and criticize the appeal proposal under
that policy by criticize the approved
proposal under
in terms of the
affair
um so I do I do criticize the or I
assess
the failure of the scheme against the uh
courses
21 22 23. just take it in stages where
do you assess as you agreed was
necessary the proposals against the
development plan read as a whole for the
purposes of section 38 6.
thank you
foreign
that's the first quote any policy
page 18 of my proof
is to policy sp22
and the failing of the scene to actually
meet the requirements of that policy in
relation to
types
sizes
and then I compare what's required under
the smart and under the local housing
needs assessment to what has been
proposed
I also
in fact back in some elements of the
student but actually
the
minimum standards for sizes appearance
and how that is being effective
including over the field
uh
and then
and then I
um
balances together the the
FBA or demonstrates that
30% offers
or should not be provided
my question was we agreed earlier that
you have to assess the development the
subject of the planning application
against the development plan read as a
whole for the birds the paragraphs
you've taken us two don't do that
could you clarify your question because
I've just taken you to
three policies where I did assess the
impact of development when you say the
plan as a whole I don't I don't know
what you mean by that if I've if I need
to join are you asking me to point out
more policies or a different part of my
plan
I already agreed it's a necessary stage
if the decision-making process for the
decision maker to assess the proposal
against the development plan read as a
whole
we've looked at the council's reason for
refusal and statement of case which
don't identify any policy breach and I'm
asking you where in your proof for the
purpose of section 38 6 you reach a
conclusion against the development plan
read as a whole
with
good plan
the other elements of The Proposal have
been accepted
and or could be addressed in terms of
the reasons for Ephesian food the
contributions and the mitigation
we're having
provided a paragraph to say read as a
whole
this theme
this appear proposal is unacceptable
because it might my proof doesn't go to
that my proof simply seems to identify
um
the policies and their affordable
housing or the lack of affordable
housing
but it's clear from that answer Mr
Hester isn't it that you haven't
actually applied section 38 6 as part of
your balancing exercise
will
I think
um
subjected by local residents and other
elements of The Proposal which the local
family Authority are not
being in evidence uh in relation to
those matters
um so for that for that reason
it's not necessarily a lively to cover
every other development plan policy in
relation to Newport exposure because I
I've actually focused
my attention on the reasons foreign
plan and how the appeal proposal should
be assessed against that
at the end of the day there is a a
judgment that you need to get that you
will come to where you
will
assess the harm against the benefits of
the appear scheme
and in terms of your proof please then I
just want to be
Crystal Clear where do you where do I
find the analysis that assesses the
proposal against the policy wording of
for example cs21
actually sp21
analysis of how the scheme relates to an
SP 21 begins at
um 3.8
as to how these relate to each other and
my response to you is the same
as I'm about to give is that
because the proposal
first
requirements under SP 23 and there is an
assessment as to whether
assessment
um
has been undertaken by the financial
liability equations and this
and
therefore that then denied me
because of the way that activity is
prepared rules into play SP 22
and SP 21 because because this scheme
cannot deliver
the correct number of affordable housing
we then have to
as part of considering the robustness of
the FBA I wonder why
it depends and so therefore that's how
they
um that that's how the proof takes goes
forward that's how my evidence goes
forward in the proof
started recipe 2122
um because sp23 isn't met and is
anything but that's a matter of judgment
um and obviously in the planning parents
that you will
um go through the levels of harm
it benefits from the skin
so if we take up please
CD 5.1 the local plan
and it's internal page 56 policy SP 21
.
which specific words within SP 21 do you
draw attention to
in order to suggest that there's a
breach of this policy
excuse me as I've just said that because
there is a breach of policy SP 23
my evidence is suggesting that we need
to then
the requirements of other policies in
relation to a housing scheme on the site
and the point in my truth with regard to
policy SP 21 is that it is a strategic
site
the
um actually if we reduce the number of
just as applied to buy if you reduce the
number of houses to below 500
500 is professional for strategic sites
it actually doesn't become a strategic
certainly but in relation to sp21 a
minimum of 3.4 hectares of open space
is required to
the dependent scheme is to provide 6.3
hectares of open space
and I would ask the question
houses
and so
creating of the skin
to stick to the minimum of 4.4 hectares
of open space
it released another 1.9
hectares of developable area
so the point being is that actually
there is a way of looking at this where
we might be able to get more affordable
housing
so my criticism of SP 21
comes from the failure of the scheme to
deliver under sp23
um and that's how I've approached this
issue
sorry Mr I have to ask again because
my question related to an assessment of
the application proposals against the
wording of SP 21 and I'm inviting you to
identify for the inspector which words
with an SP 21 you rely on in support of
a breach of that policy we're going to
come to sp23 once we've dealt with this
and sp22 and I need to because this is a
point that's not flagged at all in the
reason for refusal it's not Flags in the
statement of case your proof of ever
doesn't doesn't analyze a breach against
the wording of SP 21 you seem to be
suggesting there is such a breach
um I've referred to the case law that
makes clear it has to be assessed
against the wording of the policy this
is your opportunity to identify why the
appeal scheme is inconsistent with the
wording of this policy
space The Proposal provides for 6.3
which is generous and over supplies
and that normally wouldn't be an issue
but because we haven't got enough
affordable housing on the site and that
part of that is related to the fact that
there isn't enough housing on the site
opposed
I I've suggested to you that
the scheme
should
or the the FCA Factory that
if we increase the housing on the site
the speed will become more viable so I
probably I pull to that first section of
the 4.4 as I do refer to that
in my proof
but actually that means that is a factor
in your decision in your determination
of the of the robustness of the appeal
proposal and the FDA
we will come back to some of the
constraints on the site
later Mr Hester but plainly
a policy that requires a minimum of 4.4
hectares of open space is not breached
by a proposal that in a parameter plan
provides more than that
so Mr Williams asked me the same
question and my answer is the same
um The Proposal needs to be looked at
because there's a there's a breach of
the affordable housing policy of
providing 30 and therefore
yeah
the the appeal proposal should not be
seen as this is the only scheme this is
the only scheme in town
this is a scheme that's been put forward
by the appearance that's their story it
does not conform to the councils
courses on
sp22 and it doesn't conform to policy on
sp23 so I'm identifying where the scheme
could be improved without
um
could be improved and provide more
housing and therefore provide more
affordable housing
if
the developer area was increased and as
I referred in my examination with
reference to thickening up
Heights locations the typography of the
land Etc
so
we haven't seen any other chain any
other schemes this is the scheme that's
been presented this is the scheme before
you to determine
but because it lacks the correct level
of affordable housing I think it's quite
right that we challenge
some of the assumptions some of some of
the elements of the skin in order to see
whether we can either or get to see
delivered more affordable housing on the
side
so miss Hester I'm not asking the same
question I asked you to identify which
words you say are conflicted with by the
appeal scheme you said it's those words
only those words my point is that an
application scheme that provides for
more than 4.4 hectares of open space
cannot conflict with a requirement for a
minimum of 4.4 hectares
because the skin doesn't deliver your
food or housing level then it should
you then have to look at why that isn't
the case and one of the reasons why it
isn't the case is because the steam over
provides on open space if they step to
4.4 hectares
we see a little bit of the country to
the policy it will still be in
accordance with SP 21 and it's worth 6.3
hectaresp in accordance with policy SP
21 but the implications of over
providing open space
that directly affects the amount of food
or housing that can be provided through
the skin and that is the issue under
that policy okay and can we conclude or
agree that there's nothing in Sp 21 to
provide a minimum amount of housing
yeah
or a minimum amount of affordable
housing
because that's covered by other policies
and if you look at the introductory text
at 3.18 please on page 48
.
it's on page 48.
sorry 3.18
so
do you think the first sentence
the allocations represent the
anticipated maximum land requirements
yes
um and if we then go back then please
to s p
22.
page 58
[Music]
this is an outline application
which does not fix
the mix of market and affordable
housings
um but because the FBA is based on a set
type number size mix of dwelling
then look automatically and and
therefore to justify providing less than
30 affordable housing in my view and
triggers whether the FBA has been
carried out on the basis of a policy
compliance proposal and policy SP 22
sets out
in 34 ways as to what is expected and
certainly Imperial attacks what is
expected as part of a proposal so the
answer to Mr President's question
it is correct with the scheme
or others the steam had delivered 30
affordable housing
a little bit agreed at this stage to
consider SP 22 because that will be
picked up to a detailed at the stage but
leave aside the FBA for the moment
because that's not
actually part of the
planning permission
the outline application because it's an
outline application and will have a
condition requiring the mix to be
addressed at Reserve matter stage is
compliant with sp22
no because you cannot we cannot separate
these out if we are if if the Appellate
position we are experiences because sp23
is not being met
that then leads us to consider the
adequacy of the financial viability
appraisal
and therefore we have to consider what
sizes and types have been have been put
forward under that to see whether it's
policy component
and then we compare what's in the FDA
with sp22 types of sizes
but because an outside stage
it's clear that the those types of sizes
dwellings would not fall part of the
detailed in terms of the what's been
assessed as under the FDA you have to
consider it now
you repeatedly referred to sp23 I'm
asking you about sp22 recognizing that
this is an outline application which
will leave
type and size of dwellings to be
addressed at Reserve matters
as such the outline application cannot
be in conflict with sp22
that question
I don't think you can separate SB 22 and
23 if
sp23 is being bruised and the appellant
is seeking to justify why that policy
can decrease because sp22 is really
related to
Independence argument that the scheme
isn't viable
so
on its own that detailed letter stage
sp22 would cocaine
but this is
the question if if
the opponent had proposed 30 affordable
housing
there wouldn't have been a need for the
FBA and the end of policy between SP 23
would have been complied with but there
would have been no need to go to sp22 at
this stage
but there is no need to go to sp22
because the outline permission won't fix
the mix
so we do need to go to sp22 because the
proposal does not include 30 full
housing
important for the failure of the FBA to
consider a policy component approach
that's why sp22 is important at this
stage to consider that's my final answer
well further question
as for SP 21
what words within SP 22 do you draw to
the inspector's attention in support of
an assertion that the appeal application
for outline planning permission
contravenes sp22
so because of the because of the outline
planning applications is accompanied by
an FBA which seeks to justify an
underposition of affordable housing
based on the opponent's mix and type of
housing
I believe you should be looking at sap
to point to in relation to how that
differs or how those types of mixes
differ to the FBA and so therefore you
should look at certainly the Preamble
because a lot of that comes from the spa
but in terms of providing
proposals for Housing Development will
be expected to provide an appropriate
mix of market and affordable housing
types and sizes
and this may be revealed
so
my answer to the question so is that
actually
this is this policy remains relevant at
this stage and I do not think it is
correct and I think it will be
misleading if we separated it from SB 23
in view of the
uh assumptions included in the FBA to
justify why less than 30 percent of all
the housing should come forward
so you just aren't the answer to the
question is the words that you refer to
within the policy of supporting a breach
of the outline application are
proposals will be expected to provide an
appropriate mix of market and affordable
housing
recommendations as may be reviewed so
and that will be considered
at the reserve matters stage
that will be considered at the reserve
metal stage but at this stage the
council for an outline application that
was being asked to consider less than 30
affordable housing and therefore
SB 22 because of the
even though there is nothing or
23 please looking at the wording of the
policy
we can agree that a proposal that
provides a percentage of affordable
housing below the 30 percent will comply
with this policy where the amount of
affordable housing is Justified on
viability ground
yes where it's been demonstrated again
and paragraph
3.36 of the supporting text on page 59
confirms that negotiating this is in the
context of viability negotiating
elements of affordable housing and new
schemes will contribute valuably to
meeting local need
that's what that's right and it's also
clear from 338 isn't it that
site-specific considerations will be
taken into account
that's right
in terms of the Strategic priority point
that you refer to strategic priority
three is on page 16 of the plan
yes
these are priorities that are to be
delivered through the planned policies
sorry Mr Williams
um
[Music]
sorry page 16 strategic priorities these
are priorities that are to be delivered
through the application of the
development plan policies
yes
and in terms of providing
homes and affordable
homes
um
if you look at policy SP 13 please
which is on page 45 of the internal
pagination yes
the housing requirement
over the planned period is 17
140 units
yes
and if you then look
at table three
yes on page 46.
the identified sources of Supply in that
table
add up to eighteen thousand four hundred
and fifty Seven
um sorry table three table three
points
you have to add up the figures
now this is a comparison of Supply
against requirements the requirement is
17 140.
the identified Supply is eighteen
thousand four hundred and fifty Seven
yes yes
about a thousand over what was uh what
was required thirteen hundred
approximately
so in terms of strategic priority three
in terms of delivering the homes to meet
the needs of the district that was
assessed as being met by the delivery of
410 over the plan period
and that's consistent with
um the Strategic priorities having
maximum delivery figures it allows for
some flexibility
thank you
that's right isn't it
So when you say relax for some
flexibility I don't understand your
question well the way that local plans
are put together ordinarily to allow for
the requirement for flexibility in the
framework
is that there is an over provision of
potential Supply against the requirement
in order to allow for some flexibility
and my point is that's consistent with
what we see that all of the
statutory priority allocations are given
us notional maximum amounts
of two figures
yes
um but in reality and I think it's born
out
um
has to be provided
uh but
there are many occasions where the exact
figure isn't met and there can be an
increase or a decrease in because
put forward
um and so there is that Flex in there
um but I think the thousands of extra
thousand was down to the need to make up
for and also to boost the supply of
housing in the district because
sometimes uh there's a slow
housing trajectory and therefore
you need to you need to rely on
other circumstances and maybe other
sites coming forward at the same time
so
I mean this is the local plan is an
exercise of identifying me and seeking
to meet it
um but it's except for the site once you
get to the detailed stage you know you
do you do have a variation I think
they've said that you might prove it
there is a you would expect a variation
we can expected variation from the
number identified
in the local plan because you tend to
have a more specific scheme drawn up for
that particular site
yeah and my point is that the way the
plans put together consistent with
strategic priority three and the
provision of maximum amount for the
Strategic priorities reflects that
there's no certainty as to what any
given site will deliver
at the local plan stage
that's correct yes I mean we do have a
you do have an idea you don't have an
idea that there will be some variation
um but Mr clear for it I'd like to make
the point that I don't think the council
thought that they would be a reduction
of 100 units from this particular site
uh if it did it wouldn't be considered a
strategic site allocation anymore
because a member will drop below 500 so
yeah the United's question but also to
provide you with some background I don't
think it was in the council's
anticipation that any proposal for 450
sure
it would come forward on the site and
um in the way that it has there's
actually that's a loss of 100 units
it becomes an issue if the federal
housing isn't going to be provided
I'm going to come back to some of those
more detailed points probably tomorrow
now
um
but in terms of the viability component
of sp23
it's correct isn't it that the council
have been advised on this application by
specialist surveyors through the Dixon
cell partnership
yes yes
and also
um went to the time and expense of
having it verified by a specialist cost
Consultants yes they did that as well
now
just in terms of
Your Role at this inquiry
you don't hold out
um any or you don't possess or refer to
any qualifications in surveying or
quantity surveying that I can see
referred to in your
assessment
and when you're making everyone very
excited about the appearance of Mr
crudry and the introduction to the dark
arts but my my point is that when it
comes to I'm not in any sense being
critical of you but just in terms of
where the respective roles lie
going to go to the appropriateness of
valuation inputs and outputs aren't
matters within your expertise their
matters within either the surveyors or
the quantity surveys
it's also can answer that question in
this way I mean I've been involved with
a number of
fdas in my
roles as in in terms of what I do
why not and don't get involved with the
dark Arc of costs and values
but I did and have been involved with
well what are the policy approaches to
FBA so
but I the answer to that question is if
I mean I'm a planning to sell to know
because surveyor but I do have a basic
understanding of how to go about
uh
making sure that fdas are affected in
the correct assumptions
and in this particular case the
assumptions around well I mean when I
first when I was first instructed on
this particular
you know probably my first question was
well where's the policy compliant FBA in
order to lay the Baseline for how we
consider this and of course one is it
required so one hasn't been selected so
I do have a basic understanding of what
goes in and what comes out but I don't
I'm certainly not involved with working
out costs and values
um
see matters of sort of policy approach
for you
um but where valuation assumptions have
to be made you've deferred to Dixon's
cell
yeah so I think that's I think that's
where the I think that's why Dickson
asked to be involved at the very outset
because of their
their expertise on costs and values
which they they set out on their their
review document and where costs are
concerned so valuation assumptions
diction so where costs are concerned
that was a combination of dicks and sell
and the specialist quantity surveyors
yes I think I think that I can't
remember the chronology of it but I
think
um there wasn't any dispute between the
two of them you know
okay and you my point is you defer to
those Personnel on those matters yes yes
and if we just look at the viability
statement at Common Ground please
[Music]
and
paragraph
3.12 please
do you have that yes thank you
it Remains the position as I understand
it that dicks and cell
assess the costs and values inputted
into the FBA and whether these figures
in the position put forward were
reasonable
so the the LPA considers that was and is
the position but notes that Dixon cell
were not asked to address matters of
policy compliance
under
clinical strength and everything else
but the apparent the purpose of spearing
it out this way is that repellent
considers
that the assumptions in relation to size
mixing types were considered and
accepted by officers and their
Consultants Dixon cell
um
so I just want to make that distinction
so in other words
in my view
your parent is incorrect in assuming
that it's a cell
accepted size mixing types they went
after church to go to that and their
appraising
but my point in taking you to that was
just
to set the ground really that where
you've come in as you've explained
doesn't alter the valuation assumptions
and the cost inputs it's in relation to
those specific points that relate to
seismix and type
yeah
policy compliance schemes like only I've
asked them to do that since
the policy compliance and I did look at
sales reps and times I only responded to
the inputs of costs and values that the
theater they were not asked to do their
own liability assessment and they were
asked to assess the FBI
prepare the objectives
the point I'm trying to make I'm not
trying to over complicate it I'm trying
to identify the questions that are
properly questions for you rather than
Dixon cell who of course aren't here and
it seems to be that those relate to
questions of size mix and type of units
which you're saying have matters for you
not bits and sell matters
yeah
well what matters for me are policy
what's a policy compliant FBA that's
that's the matter for me and yes science
looks and types are important because
that's obviously identified in the
policy which has been 22.
um so yes that that is my role
um in terms of
my input that IPL
briefly sorry Mr Williams but just in
terms of time because we are approaching
five o'clock I'm just thinking about
when will be a convenient place for you
to sort of break off before you get into
another sort of line in questioning I
don't know how long this one this little
theme is going to go but in terms of how
long do you think you've got in this
trunch of questions so to speak I've got
that in mind I think we'll reach a
convenient point in about five minutes
okay
it went unfortunately be the end of all
the questions on viability but it will
be a convenient stopping point I
understand okay yeah that's that's fine
thank you sorry for interrupting Mr
Andrew I just then wanted to look at the
council statement to the case please
okay
paragraph
um
2.6
just donate the second
sentence there
that the
um DSP
review
considered the submitted approach to
viability to be appropriate including
values and costs and the outputs
resulting from the assumptions taken
yes I think the election was that it was
fair
we'll we'll come back to that that's not
quite right that's one word used I'm
taking you deliberately to what the
council said its case was in its
statement of case
um
in terms of
numbers
to assess a scheme on the basis of 550
units that's obviously not something
that anyone has done at this inquiry is
it
yeah
I mean to assess that scheme or such a
notion or scheme would be to assess
something for which permission hasn't
been sought
now the points that you
we've just been talking about
type size and mix
we looked at this in the context of sp22
the actual mix delivered on the site is
dependent on the approval of Reserve
matters isn't it that's correct
and does not fall for determination at
this inquiry
and
I'm going to come back to this tomorrow
but just to
have a high level answer now
the alternative mixes and types of units
assessed by Dixon cell Partnerships at
your request
actually provide lower
residualized land values than the mix
assessed by J.L and put forward by
gladman for the purposes of the FBA
I don't know
well it's probably just a good short
point
to finish
if you look at your appendix
be
I know this has been slightly corrected
that the changes are proportionate
it will take me to I found it now
because you take me to where you want it
to be page 11.
yes
do you see the indicative rlv column
yeah
the first one is the gladman mix
adjusted for size
then you've got version two the 2016
schmar mix and version three the 2021
and 18. uh paper mix the one that
produces the highest indicative rlv I.E
the most valuable mix and time
is the gladman mix
yes it's got the most Surplus yeah
So when you say Dixon cell didn't
consider the appropriateness of type and
mix in fact when you ask them to
consider those matters
in line with your evidence it drove the
value down
well it took a glad and profit level to
19 percent it has built a profit level
to 18.1 percent
um to visit your land value
is the highest from the gladman mix
isn't it yes it is
and you
and or Dixon cell haven't assessed any
mix or identified any mix that would
create a higher land value
than the gladman mix that's correct
thank you sir I think that would be a
convenient point to stop thank you very
much
thank you thank you
and uh thank you Mr Hester I hope you
also continue to feel okay
so we probably all have uh thank you but
so yeah I hope you're feeling well
enough tomorrow morning so I hope you
get a chance to have some sort of rest
uh this evening I should say too that uh
it probably goes about saying that you
shouldn't talk to your Advocate Mr Upson
sort of probably during
cross-examination we're not talking
across examination so if you can refrain
from from doing that I'm sure that with
the case anyway
um and then we'll continue tomorrow
morning again at 9 30 which I'm assuming
is going to be okay for everybody
um
just in case we said we'd have a little
sort of look back at
timing it it looks to me as though we
sort of almost I think odds on now to go
into Friday I would imagine from where
we are
but I think that's definitely the case
uh to be honest how long more do you
think Mr Williams in terms of your
cross-examination of Mr Hester
approximately just well with the other
things it has taken me slightly longer
than I had anticipated I'm afraid
um
probably
if I review some notes an hour
okay
um
so let's just think Cruz it was just
thinking for a sort of outline going
ahead as we're
so that'll take us to say let's say
quarter to 11 and destruction in terms
of sort of re-examination how long
roughly
I don't know not very long because
obviously Mr Hester has been able to
elaborate on his explanations so there's
there's nothing really substantial at
the moment
okay so take us to mid morning
uh okay so and then we'll have uh
the opponent's witness of course
well both the panels Witnesses so yeah
it is going to be it may be that we get
to consider uh
conditions tomorrow afternoon maybe
conditions and uh yeah section 106 with
a good wind but
I think and if everything else is going
to be beyond beyond that I do want to
stick to five o'clock because I don't
think for everybody it's fair to go
beyond five o'clock so uh okay uh
any more little housekeeping matters
before we finish for the day
not from me thank you sir
no nothing from us thank you no okay
okay good uh well thank you again uh for
everyone's contributions today I'll
adjourn the inquiry now till